la séance est reprise je vais donner la
parole à Monsieur le Président Alain
Richard pour une mise au point au sujet
d'un vote de la parole madame la
Présidente
d'hier sur le scrutin numéro 5 sur le la
proposition de loi relative
aux étudiants internes en médecine je
souhaitais m'abstenir et j'ai été porté
comme votant pour et je voulais signaler
pour le procès-verbal que il en va de
même de mon collègue Michel lacbet
et je donnais la parole à Madame
Ghislaine pour également pour une mise
au point sujet d'un vote merci de
m'avoir présidente donc je vous remercie
de bien vouloir noter que leur discuter
numéro 3 je souhaitais voter pour merci
merci à tes données de ces mises au
point elles seront publiées au Journal
officiel et figurant dans l'analyse
politique des scrutin
mes chers collègues par courrier en date
du mardi 18 octobre monsieur le
Président Guillaume comptard président
du groupe écologiste solidarité
territoire demande que le projet de loi
autorisant la ratification du traité
entre la République française et la
République italienne pour une
coopération bilatérale renforcée inscrit
à l'ordre du jour du jeudi 27 octobre à
10h30 soit examiné selon la procédure
normale et non selon la procédure
simplifiée acte et donner de cette
demande dans la discussion générale nous
pourrions attribuer un temps de 45
minutes aux orateurs des groupes le
délai limite pour les inscriptions de
parole seraient fixées au mercredi 26
octobre à 15h il n'y a pas de position
on est ainsi décidé
en application du cinquième alinéa de
l'article 13 de la Constitution ainsi
que de la loi organique et de la loi
ordinaire du 23 juillet 2010 prise pour
son application la commission des
finances a émis lors de sa réunion du
mardi 18 octobre 2022 un avis favorable
20 voies pour une voix compte à la
nomination du madame Marianne
barbalayani à la présidence de
l'Autorité des marchés financiers
la parole est au président Patrick
canard pour un rappel au règlement
oui merci madame la Présidente très très
simplement nous allons aborder dans
quelques instants une proposition de loi
extrêmement importante très symbolique
qui est celle de la
constructionnalisation de l'IVG donc
dans notre texte fondamental
c'est une un moment important qui
d'ailleurs a fait l'objet d'un avis
favorable historiquement de la part du
gouvernement et nous savons dans quel
contexte nous allons aborder cette
discussion un contexte de remise en
cause de ce droit et donc de nombreux
pays et y compris des pays européens
donc il ne faut passer du temps il faut
passer de l'énergie il faut surtout de
la conviction en la matière et je
regrette très simplement que au même
moment nous ayons plusieurs commissions
trois commissions je crois qu'il sur une
liste dont la commission des affaires
sociales je m'en suis ouvert récemment
président l'archet sur un autre débat le
débat concernant les droites et femmes
iraniennes et leurs combats et nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans la même
situation donc je souhaite vraiment même
si je sais que nous travaillons beaucoup
qu'il y a beaucoup de dossiers
aujourd'hui en cours au sein de notre
assemblée vraiment qu'il y ait
et le ministre Braun qui l'audition au
même moment donc le ministre bronze qui
est aussi concerné par définition qui
est là donc ce sont des moments
importants que beaucoup de nos collègues
vont devoir se priver en se partageant
entre les travaux de commission et notre
séance plénière donc je voulais faire ce
rappel au règlement et je ne doute pas
que nos collègues du groupe écologiste
du groupe geste pardon seront aussi
associés à cette démarche par le biais
de leur Président je vous remercie merci
à tes données de votre rappel aux
règlements et la parole est donc à
monsieur le Président Guillaume Gontard
pour un rappel au règlement également
merci merci madame la Présidente
évidemment j'irai dans le même sens que
que pratique Patrick Kanner que je
remercie pour pour ce qui vient de dire
c'est vrai que je pense qu'il y a quand
même un vrai un vrai problème on est sur
des textes sur des textes importants
avec l'IVG l'inscription de l'IVG dans
la Constitution qui va demander du débat
qui est particulièrement
regarder et observer un texte sur le
droit des sages-femmes et c'est vrai que
dans le même moment et dans cette niche
de 4 heures on a l'audition notamment du
du ministre de la santé mais pas que
puisqu'on a deux autres commissions qui
auditionnent des ministres donc c'est
vrai que je pense qu'il faut qu'on
préserve ce travail parlementaire qu'on
préserve aussi la question du travail
dans les dans le cadre des des niches
donc voilà moi j'en appelle à la fois
aussi notamment aux présidentes et
présidente et président de commission
pour qu'il soit attentif et que on
essaye pour les prochaines fois de faire
en sorte qu'on n'est pas que nos
collègues n'est pas des choix
particulièrement insensés voir complexe
à faire entre aller en commission ou
suivre ce débat particulièrement
important merci merci acte et donner de
votre rappel aux règlements
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion de
la proposition de loi constitutionnelle
visant à protéger et à garantir le droit
fondamental à l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse et à la contraception
présentée par Madame Mélanie Vogel et
plusieurs de ses collègues
la discussion générale la parole est à
Madame Mélanie vosgel autrice de la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle et
pour diminue de chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
Madame la Ministre madame la rapporteur
chers collègue nous sommes réunis
aujourd'hui pour répondre à une question
d'une simplicité extrême et d'une
importance majeure alors ou partout dans
le monde partout dans le monde les
forces réactionnaires progressent à
l'heure où les droits des femmes les
droits reproductifs et sexuels sont
partout attaquées à l'heure ou en Europe
les femmes se préparent à la
contre-offensive à l'heure où la France
peut retrouver un rôle de pionnière de
modèles et d'espérance nous devons
répondre à une question
préférons-nous une société où le droit à
l'avortement est protégé au sommet de la
hiérarchie des normes ou une société ou
une simple loi peut le défaire préférons
nous agir aujourd'hui au risque au pire
que cette garantie ne se révèle jamais
nécessaire ou ne rien faire au risque de
balayer le droit fondamental des
générations futures voulons-nous
répondre positivement à 80% des
Françaises et des Français toutes
catégories social préférence politique
appartenance religieuse confondues qui
demande que le droit à l'avortement soit
reconnu dans le texte qui fonde notre
contrat social ou non souhaitons nous
dire à toutes les femmes de ce pays que
le Parlement est de leur côté que
l'honneur de la France c'est son idéal
d'égalité c'est de considérer que la
maîtrise de sa font de sa fécondité est
une affaire de liberté mais aussi
simplement une affaire de citoyenneté
d'égalité des droits et que pour cette
raison nous les régions au sommet de nos
normes souhaitons-nous montrer à toutes
les femmes du monde à toutes celles et
ceux qui se battent si nombreuses et si
nombreux contre le fascisme contre le
totalitarisme religieux celui des Molay
iraniens des évangélistes Texans ou des
intégristes bien français à toutes
celles et ceux qui en Pologne en gris en
Italie aux États-Unis en Iran au Maroc à
Malte dans tant de pays se battent pour
avoir le droit d'être considéré comme
des êtres humains qui disposent de leur
corps et au fond de leur destin et de
leur vie que non tout n'est pas perdu
que dans cette période si sombre il
existe
tout le monde un chemin un chemin de
progrès dans lequel notre pays a fait le
choix de s'engager et dans lequel il
invite les autres nations elle y
rejoindre le droit l'avortement est un
acquis féministe et comme tous les
acquis féministes il n'est jamais hors
de danger jamais c'est aussi un acquis
profondément républicain parce qu'il
répond à la promesse républicaine et
universaliste d'égalité des droits un
acquis qu'il vous est simplement proposé
aujourd'hui de mieux protéger où trouver
l'envie en 2022 d'argumenter contre une
loi qui ne ferait rien d'autre que de
sanctuariser un droit que prétendument
nous chérissons tout et tous c'est je
vous l'assure pour tellement de
personnes qui nous regardent un profond
mystère
je remercie évidemment madame la
rapporteur pour son travail je sais que
cela n'a pas toujours été le travail le
plus facile mais je voudrais revenir sur
les arguments utilisés pour refuser
cette loi
premièrement l'argument classique ça ne
sert à rien d'abord parce que ce droit
n'est pas menacé donc c'est un peu comme
dire je suis dans ma voiture ça sert à
rien que je mette ma ceinture parce que
je ne suis pas en train d'avoir un
accident
cette argument n'a évidemment aucun sens
parce que par définition on se protège
d'un risque avant qu'il advienne mais
aussi parce qu'on le sait très bien le
jour où il aura un risque concret en
France c'est-à-dire quoi un nombre
conséquent d'élus tenter de remettre en
cause ce droit et bien ce jour-là une
protection constitutionnelle sera par
définition hors de portée puisque la
majorité pour changer la Constitution
est supérieure à celle pour changer la
loi et que c'est précisément pour ça que
nous voulons l'inscrire dans la
Constitution c'est donc exactement parce
qu'il existe aujourd'hui en France une
écrasante majorité dans les dans la rue
dans les institutions pour le droit à
l'avortement que l'on peut et que l'on
doit le protéger maintenant deuxièmement
ça ne sert à rien parce que c'est pas
une protection absolue la Constitution
peut toujours la modifier donc là c'est
je mets pas ma ceinture de sécurité
parce que on sait pas il peut y avoir un
tsunami alors c'est pas faux on n'est
jamais à l'abri d'un putsch d'une
révolution d'un astéroïde qui
percuterait la France donc je suis même
pas tout à fait sûr de savoir au fond
pourquoi on a une constitution des élus
qui se lèvent le matin pour légiférer de
toute façon il y a des gens qui violent
la loi tous les jours et il y a des élus
qui changent la loi en permanence donc
on a quand même d'un côté ça sert à rien
parce qu'il y a pas de risque et de
l'autre ça sert à rien parce que le
risque est trop grand donc c'est un peu
difficile à suivre mais c'est pas fini
troisième argument ça ne sert à rien
parce que c'est déjà protégé par la
Constitution donc en fait je dois pas
mettre ma ceinture parce que je l'ai
déjà il faut surtout pas mettre sa
ceinture parce qu'il y a pas de risque
le risque est trop grand et finalement
mesdames et messieurs parce que
heureusement je l'ai déjà donc c'est
assez épatant et pas encore le problème
c'est que c'est faux la jurisprudence du
Conseil constitutionnel n'a jamais
dégagé de manière positive un droit à
l'interrupteur à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse jamais elle
s'est contentée d'affirmer que les
différentes lois qui en cas de droit à
l'IVG ne violaient pas d'un Constitution
et les fins juristes que vous êtes
connaissent très bien la différence si
demain et ça toutes les personnes qui
nous écoutent doivent le savoir si
demain une loi régressive qui viserait à
réduire les délais légaux à des
rembourser ajouter des conditions pour
accéder à l'avortement à imposer une
ordonnance pour accéder de la pilule du
lendemain venez à être présenté devant
le Conseil constitutionnel ce dernier
n'aurait rien pour statuer sur son
inconstitutionnalité rien et c'est ça
que nous voulons corriger
argument suivant ça ne va rien changer
parce que l'important est ailleurs comme
toujours ce n'est pas le droit c'est
l'accès aux droits alors déjà j'aimerais
vous dire une chose on n'a pas accès à
un droit qui n'existe plus et puis quel
est le rapport cette loi va non
seulement permettre de réclamer un
meilleur accès partout mais surtout elle
ne vous empêchera pas je vous l'assure
jamais bien au contraire de voter pour
l'augmentation des crédits pour les
associations et les centres de soins pas
du tout
argument suivant la Constitution ne doit
pas être un catalogue et n'a pas à
protéger les Français contre des
changements par exemple faire reculer le
droit l'avortement qu'il pourrait
démocratiquement vouloir demain et ben
si parce que dans ce cas là à quoi ça
sert d'avoir une constitution et un bloc
de constitutionnalité à quoi ça sert de
protéger le caractère laïque de la
République notre attachement au
préambule de 46 l'interdiction de la
peine de mort rien dans ce cas là
le dernier argument et je j'avoue c'est
un peu mon préféré il faut pas importer
des débats des États-Unis
comme s'il n'y avait que aux États-Unis
qu'on attaquait le droit à l'IVG en
Italie donc juste à côté une proposition
loi vient d'être déposée par la droite
pas par l'extrême droite par la droite
pour restreindre le droit à l'avortement
mais en France on serait nationalement
immunisé puis je trouve que nous avons
d'un côté de cette hémicycle une haine
très sélective des importations de débat
en particulier venant des États-Unis
parce que quand il s'agit d'importer des
débats totalement construits au sujet
d'un prétendu danger causé par un
prétendu concept dont personne ne se
réclame en France et que personne n'est
capable de définir c'est bien mais quand
les débats prétendument importer à
propos de risques bien réels peuvent
générer des progrès bien réels là c'est
mal alors admettons mettez moi de côté
mais Laurence Rossignol qui le porte
depuis 2012 Elian assassy Laurence Cohen
qui dès 2017 5 ans avant l'arrêt de la
cour de suprême avait déjà fait cette
proposition daphnéak Madou Xavier
yakovelli Maryse Carrère jouait de
gueriau toujours merci une fois encore
ces gens-là ne sont pas importés je suis
désolé ils sont bien ici il pose ici au
Sénat français une question bien
française la France a en son cœur des
femmes qui depuis des siècles se battent
pour conquérir leurs droits à elle et
par la même pour protéger les droits
tout court alors je vais vous dire une
chose si vous devez y avoir aujourd'hui
une spécificité française ce ne serait
pas d'être prétendument le seul pays au
monde protégé des recules ce serait au
contraire de devenir le premier pays au
monde à décider d'agir en amont plutôt
que de réagir quand il est trop tard en
tant que coprésidente du Parti vert
européen partageons ma vie avec une
féministe allemande qui se bat depuis
toujours pour quand l'Allemagne
l'avortement soit retiré du droit du
code pénal je peux vous dire une chose
vous mesurez très mal très mal
l'importance pour l'Europe entière du
vote d'aujourd'hui la force que cela
donnerait à des millions de défenseuses
et de défenseurs des droits humains
elles ne peuvent être méprisées par le
pays qui se veut celui des droits
universels j'ai passé
ces dernières semaines
des jours et des nuits à chercher
quels arguments marcheraient le mieux
pour convaincre la droite sénatoriale de
voter ce texte au nom de ce que je crois
être le sens profond de notre mandat et
puis je me suis dit qu'en fait
c'était à vous de convaincre de
convaincre les Françaises et les
Français que le droit à l'avortement est
pour vous vraiment un droit fondamental
vous avez la majorité c'est vrai une
victoire aujourd'hui serait la vôtre et
un échec aussi
je voudrais finir en m'adressant à
toutes les personnes mobiliser qui nous
écoutent et qui attendent de nous que
nous les protions je veux vous dire
je ne sais pas si on va y arriver
aujourd'hui
mais je sais qu'on y arrivera un jour et
je sais que ce jour tous ceux qui
s'opposent aujourd'hui à ce progrès
l'applaudiront très fort on se rend très
fiers tandis qu'ils seront encore très
occupés en freiner d'autres alors ne
lâchez rien jamais c'est vous par votre
mobilisation qui depuis toujours
écrivait l'histoire et en particulier
l'histoire des combats des droits des
femmes je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Madame Agnès
canaguet rapporteur de la commission des
lois pour 10 minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
des sceaux madame la ministre monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
mes chers collègues le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et la contraception font partie
intégrante de notre patrimoine juridique
fondamental ces acquis ont été obtenus
grâce au courage et à l'engagement de
Simone Veil et de Lucien Nevers qui se
sont battus avec détermination pour les
faire inscrire dans la loi aujourd'hui
ses droits sont pleinement protégés par
le droit positif le Sénat c'est toujours
montré fortement attaché à ces libertés
de la femme depuis la loi du 17 janvier
1975 la liberté d'interrompre sa
grossesse n'a cessé d'être conforté par
cette foi le législateur l'a renforcé
avec encore récemment l'allongement du
délai à 14 semaines quant à la
contraception consacrée par la loi du 28
décembre 1967
son accès n'a cessé d'être étendu au fil
des années la contraception est délivrée
gratuitement pour les mineurs depuis
cette année elle est pour toutes les
femmes de moins de 26 ans et à partir de
2023 la contraception d'urgence sera
gratuite pour toutes les femmes
aujourd'hui à ma connaissance personne
dans certains assemblée ne veut revenir
sur ses avancées la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle dont nous avons à
débattre aujourd'hui et partez et porter
par notre collègue mais la niveau gel
est consignée par 118 sénateurs elle a
été introduite en réaction à l'actualité
américaine marquée par le revirement de
la jurisprudence de la Cour suprême du
24 juin dernier dops versus Jackson
cette proposition de loi
constitutionnelle tente à inscrire au
titre 8 de la Constitution un article
66.2 qui affirme nul ne peut porter
atteinte au droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse et à la
contraception la loi garantit à toute
personne qui en fait la demande là c'est
l'accès libre et effectif assez droit
selon les auteurs cette inscription vise
à garantir un accès effectif libre et
inconditionnel à l'IVG ainsi qu'à la
contraception et à prévenir de toute
régression si l'on peut comprendre
l'émotion susciter outre-Atlantique par
la jurisprudence de la Cour suprême la
révision constitutionnelle ne peut être
en France une réponse pertinente tout
d'abord il n'y a pas lieu d'importer en
France un débat lié à la culture
américaine et à la nature fédérale des
États-Unis ce débat n'est pas le nôtre
la situation institutionnelle en France
n'étant rien comparable à celle des
Etats-Unis contrairement à ces derniers
la République française est une et
intolidible autrement dit les lois
veillent et nevirtz qui se sont pas
remises en cause aujourd'hui en France
s'applique de manière
identique sur tout le territoire la
question centrale en France reste
l'effectivité de ses droits
celle des mesures concrètes comme la
lutte contre les déserts médicaux
notamment milieu rural la valorisation
des actes médicaux des personnels
soignants pratiquant l'IVG
l'augmentation des moyens des plannings
familiaux permettront le plein accès à
ses droits mais ces mesures relèvent du
domaine réglementaire l'inscription dans
la Constitution n'est donc pas la
réponse adaptée pour renforcer la
garantie de ses droits inscrits dans
notre patrimoine juridique l'IVG le
droit à la contraception font déjà
l'objet d'une protection
constitutionnelle solide et durable
solide car les Végéta inscrite dans
notre droit depuis 1975 le Conseil
constitutionnel l'a toujours jugé
conforme à Camp de la Constitution et
par quatre fois c'est prononcé en faveur
de ce droit en 1975 en 2001 en 2014 en
2016 l'IVG est aujourd'hui une
composante de la liberté de la femme
découlant de l'article 2 de la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen qui se concilient avec le
principe de sauvegarde de la dignité la
personne humaine comme contre toute
forme de dégradation plus que solide
cette protection est durable comme le
témoigne la jurisprudence constante du
Conseil constitutionnel qui a toujours
considéré que bien que le législateur
dispose de large de manœuvre pour
définir les conditions d'exercice d'un
droit ou d'une liberté il ne peut en
remettre en cause son effectivité c'est
le fameux effet artichaut que nous
devons doyen favoreux on ne peut toucher
au cœur des droits et des libertés
reconnues d'ailleurs en 2018 Agnès Buzyn
et Nicole Belloubet alors ministre avait
affirmé devant le Parlement l'inutilité
d'inscrire le droit à l'IVG dans la
Constitution en les raisons de l'extrême
solidité de sa protection
constitutionnelle quatre années plus
tard la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle dont nous débattons ce
jour comporte toujours des risques
largement supérieurs à la seule portée
symbolique recherchée par les auteurs
l'inscription dans la Constitution du
droit à l'IVG à la contraception tant à
dénaturer l'esprit de la Constitution et
à ouvrir une boîte de Pandore en effet
la Constitution voulue par le général de
Gaulle est avant tout un siècle qui
régit le fonctionnement de nos
institutions en faire un catalogue de
droit risque de porter atteinte au rôle
protecteur de la norme suprême et à
minorer la portée de la jurisprudence du
Conseil constitutionnel gardien de nos
droits et de nos libertés en 2008 Simone
Veil présidente du comité de réflexion
sur le préambule de la Constitution
recommandé elle-même de ne pas modifier
le préambule ni d'intégrer dans la
constitution des droits et des libertés
liées à la bioéthique qui intégrait
l'IVG elle préconisait clairement le
refus d'inscrire des dispositions de
purement de portée purement symbolique
seuls quatre raisons justifie une
modification de la Constitution pour
introduire un droit nouveau pour déroger
à un principe que la Constitution impose
le cas en 1999 et en 2008 pour autoriser
la parité pour ratifier un engagement
international l'inscription dans la
peine dans la constitution de la peine
de mort en 2007 était nécessaire pour
entériner le Pacte international des
droits civils et politiques pour revenir
4e raison sur une interprétation
jurisprudentielle du Conseil
constitutionnel comme en 1993 pour le
droit d'asile l'objet de la proposition
de loi soumise à notre examen ne peut se
rattacher à aucune de ces raisons de
plus force est de constater qu'il
n'existe aujourd'hui aucun consensus sur
la manière de constitutionnaliser l'IVG
et le droit à la contraception 6
propositions de loi constitutionnelle
ont été introduites à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat en réaction à
l'actualité américaine chaque aucune
propose une version différente
l'inscription par défaut dans le titre 8
de la Constitution prévue par plusieurs
propositions de loi constitutionnelle
celle de la sénatrice Vogel n'est pas
satisfaisante l'intégration du droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et à la contraception au sein du titre
consacré à l'autorité judiciaire juste
après l'abolition de la peine de mort a
de quoi surprendre et pour y créer une
possible interférence du juge dans le
droit des femmes à avorter ce qui n'a
pas lieu d'être des propositions de
rattachement l'article premier ou
l'article 34 de la Constitution relatif
aux compétences du législateur ne font
pas plus consensus auprès des
constitutionnalistes de plus la
formulation soumise à notre examen
souvenait des difficultés importantes
elle laisse entendre que l'accès à ses
droits serait inconditionnel or le
législateur doit pouvoir en fixer les
conditions comme pour toutes les
libertés publiques
enfin une procédure de révision
constitutionnelle à l'initiative des
parlementaires imposent le recours au
référendum conformément à l'article 89
de la Constitution or il existe un
risque réel que cette initiative se
retourne contre les droits qu'elle est
censée protéger comme nous ont alerté
toutes les personnes auditionnées y
compris des auteurs recourir au
référendum metré au cœur d'une actualité
bouillonnante un sujet pour lequel il
n'y a pas de remise en cause et pourrait
réveiller un réveil et pourrait
favoriser par dont un réveil des
opposants n'oublions pas que l'enfer est
pavé de bonnes intentions pour toutes
ces raisons la commission des Lois vous
propose ne pas adopter cette proposition
de loi constitutionnelle
merci la parole est à monsieur Éric
Dupont-Moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice
cher Isabelle
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois
madame la rapporteur madame la sénatrice
Mélanie Vogel mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
l'histoire je le crois profondément
fourmis
d'exemples de liberté de droit
fondamentaux conquis au prix du sang
des larmes que tous croyaient
définitivement acquis
et qui dans la stupeur ou l'indifférence
ont été balayées comme des fétus de
paille
c'est d'ailleurs l'histoire de la femme
qui nous offre les plus cruelles
exemples car oui
les premiers droits qui disparaissent
sont souvent se défendre
et c'est ce que nous rappelle la
décision de la Cour suprême des
États-Unis le droit à l'avortement qu'on
croyait à qui depuis 50 ans en réalité
ne l'était pas
désormais
dans cette grande démocratie
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
n'est plus un droit garanti par la
Constitution fédérale et les États
fédérés sont libres de l'interdire ou de
la légaliser
cet exemple rend plus que jamais criant
de vérité les célèbres mots de Simone de
Beauvoir rapporté par Claudine Monteil
n'oubliez jamais qu'il suffira d'une
crise politique économique religieuse
pour que les droits des femmes soient
remis en question ces droits ne sont
jamais acquis vous devrez rester
vigilant votre vie durant
parce que nous avons en effet désormais
la preuve que plus aucune démocratie
même la plus grande d'entre toutes n'est
à l'abri
parce qu'il nous faudra toujours rester
vigilant les auteurs de la présence
proposition de loi la sénatrice Mélanie
Vogel en tête propose d'inscrire
notamment le droit à un interruption
volontaire de grossesse dans notre
Constitution je veux ici les remercier
chaleureusement pour leur initiative
le 13 juillet dernier
en accord avec la première ministre
j'avais solennellement déclaré devant
cette assemblée qu'en tant que garde des
sceaux je soutiendrai avec force pour
les voir aboutir toutes les initiatives
parlementaires qui viseraient à
constitutionnaliser le droit à l'IVG me
voici donc au rendez-vous accompagné
de ma collègue Isabelle Rome alors
j'entends déjà s'élever et j'ai entendu
s'élever
des voix pour dire que le droit à l'IVG
est déjà suffisamment protégé en France
et que l'exemple américain n'est pas
transposable dans notre pays
il aurait pu changer que le wauquisme
serait transposé dans notre pays
on pourrait multiplier les exemples la
liste est évidemment très longue
oui mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
nuls ne peut nier que nos institutions
fonctionnent différemment
oui c'est vrai le Conseil
constitutionnel français n'est pas la
Cour suprême américaine
oui bien sûr les juges constitutionnels
français passaient et actuels ont une
conscience accrue de leur rôle et jugent
régulièrement qu'il n'appartient pas au
Conseil constitutionnel de substituer
son appréciation à celle du législateur
c'est là l'usage républicain et l'esprit
de nos institutions oui il est vrai
encore que le droit à l'IVG a été
conforté au fil des ans depuis qu'il a
été consacré pour la première fois dans
notre droit par la loi veille du 17
janvier
1975 je pense ici à la dernière loi en
date du 2 mars 2022 qui a allongé le
délai légal pour recourir à l'IVG et le
porte désormais de 12 à 14 semaines je
pense aussi aux lois qui ont précédé
comme par exemple la loi du 4 août 2014
pour l'égalité réelle entre les hommes
et les femmes loi qui a supprimé le
critère de la situation de détresse pour
autant
je persiste et je signe
accompagner les initiatives
parlementaires pour graver dans le
marbre de notre Constitution le droit
fondamental à l'IVG me paraît
aujourd'hui pertinent en ces temps
troublé ou des projets politiques n'ont
certes pas cours dans cette hémicycle ou
si peu projet qui grandissent et rendent
possible des recules drastiques pour le
droit des femmes d'abord disons-le cette
inscription aurait la force du symbole
force du symbole qui n'est pas anodine
lorsque l'on parle de la loi suprême de
notre pays car oui la Constitution les
textes fondateur de notre État de droit
le choc le commun des valeurs de notre
République et des libertés fondamentales
de notre société
dès lors quel beau symbole pour la
France pays des droits de l'homme que
celui d'élever au plus haut rang de la
hiérarchie de ces normes le droit de la
femme à disposer monsieur le sénateur de
son propre corps
en ces temps de division
de perte de repères qu'elle plus beau
message envoyé à plus de la moitié de la
population française pour lui dire que
la Constitution lui garantit le droit à
disposer de son corps et donc le droit à
l'émancipation
car oui au-delà du symbole il y aurait
des conséquences concrètes alors que le
Conseil constitutionnel a rattaché l'IVG
à je cite la liberté de la femme qui
découle de l'article 2 de la Déclaration
des Droits de l'Homme et du Citoyen
inscrire l'IVG dans la Constitution
permettrait de le consacrer enfin comme
un droit fondamental et non simplement
comme une liberté autonomie comme disent
les juristes constitutionnels
mais il y a une autre raison plus
pragmatique sur laquelle je veux
insister un instant en tant que garde
des sceaux cette raison elle est
évidente changez la Constitution est
beaucoup plus difficile
de changer la loi aujourd'hui consacré
par la loi si le droit à l'IVG était
demain protégé au niveau constitutionnel
il ne pourrait être remis en cause que
par le pouvoir constituant
car cela
nécessiterait à tout le moins que les
deux chambres et vous connaissez bien
sur la règle soit d'accord pour y
consentir première difficulté et pas des
moindres puis dans un second temps que
le Parlement réunit en congrès ou que
nos concitoyens par référendum valide ce
qui serait une régression terrible pour
la condition des femmes je veux ma
pesantir un instant
pour vous dire le fond de ma pensée
du fonds de mes tripes et pardonnez-moi
cette familiarité je vais vous montrer
comment la course des choses comme
disait Alain justifie que nous
soutenions l'inscription de l'IVG dans
notre Constitution alors que Simone Veil
s'exprimait le 26 novembre
1974 devant l'Assemblée nationale pour
porter cette grande loi elle inscrivait
son projet sous le signe de l'espérance
permettez-moi humblement de reprendre
ici ces mots alors qu'elle concluait son
discours pour convaincre les députés
encore hésitants
mesdames messieurs les députés je ne
suis pas de ceux et de celles qui
redoutent l'avenir c'est simple
Simone Veil croyez profondément que la
loi qu'elle portait alors
permettrait à la Société française de
progresser et l'avenir lui a bien
heureusement donné raison mais
mais mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
j'aimerais tant vous dire à cette
tribune un 19 octobre 2022 presque 50
ans après la légalisation de
l'avortement que non moi non plus je ne
doute pas l'avenir j'aimerais tant
aujourd'hui ne pas être de ceux qui
tremblent face à l'avenir et aux
incertitudes qu'il charrie parfois
j'aimerais tant être de ceux qui
tranquille et d'un pas assuré avance
insouciant sur le chemin de la vie
croyons ce qui est acquis
et que ce qui est acquis est acquis
et que ce qui est là le sera pour
toujours j'aimerais tant enfin être de
ceux qui d'un revers de main balayant
les exemples étrangers en particulier
l'exemple américain ou le droit recule
et avec lui souvent la condition des
femmes qui peut aujourd'hui dire
ce qui s'est produit aux États-Unis
ne pourrait pas se produire en France
soyons clairs qu'est-ce qui a amené la
décision de la Cour suprême américaine
l'élection d'un président populiste
légitimement TELUS certes disposant
d'une majorité au Sénat américain qui a
pu nommer au cours de son mandat 4 juges
de la Cour suprême
pardon
je pense pas que les membres du Conseil
constitutionnels soient nommés
exclusivement par un président de la
République fut-il populiste pardon il y
aurait là de quoi déstabiliser une
véritable institution je ne pense pas
que nos textes le permettent le constat
il est simple il est simple
politiquement et juridiquement un
président ou une présidente
disposant presque naturellement d'une
majorité pourrait je dis bien pourrait
revêtir en attaque actuelle du droit sur
cette avancée historique et démocratique
que représente le droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse c'est d'ailleurs
le cas chez certains de nos voisins
européens c'est donc pour des raisons
totalement opposées à celles
de l'illustre Simone Veil
parce que précisément je redoute
l'avenir que je suis aujourd'hui
favorable à ce qu'on élève sa grande loi
celle de 1975 tel qu'aujourd'hui
modifiée sa grande conquête celle de
toutes les Françaises au sommet de la
hiérarchie des normes oui mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je veux mettre
le droit à l'IVG dans notre Constitution
là précisément où il ne sera pas
possible de l'en retirer sans l'accord
du Sénat
car je sais que là encore
il sera comme toujours le garant de nos
droits les plus fondamentaux je le dis
sans aucune flagorerie inscrire le droit
à l'IVG dans la Constitution c'est aussi
s'assurer que le Sénat dans sa grande
sagesse soit assurée d'avoir le dernier
mot si d'aventure
un président une présidente et sa
majorité souhaitait l'abroger je crois
avec force au rôle presque informel mais
pourtant bien réel et durable du Sénat
en tant que garant de notre bien commun
de notre conscience collective
on dit souvent que le président
Mitterrand a été particulièrement
courageux d'abolir en 1981 la peine de
mort alors que le compatriote y était
majoritairement opposé puisque l'on ne
dit jamais c'est que le Sénat à lui
aussi tout aussi courageusement adopté
conforme 12 jours à peine après
l'Assemblée nationale la loi que portait
alors Robert Badinter mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs ne vous trompez
pas inscrire aujourd'hui le droit à
l'IVG dans notre Constitution n'est pas
une mesure gadget
un artifice de communication ou un
mouvement de panique face à un exemple
étranger lointain inscrire le droit à
l'IVG cette liberté fondamentale et une
aliénable de la femme c'est une sécurité
pour toutes les femmes de ce pays
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
faites en sorte que personne ne puisse
abolir demain ce droit sans que vous
soyez consulté
les temps troublés et les remous ne sont
jamais loin dans le frêle esquif de la
démocratie qui mérite toute notre
attention en tant qu' ancien avocat mais
aussi en tant que citoyen j'ai toujours
essayé de faire en sorte que jamais l'on
oublie que notre démocratie notre État
de droit les libertés fondamentales
qu'il consacrent sont des biens précieux
nos joyaux communs pour lesquels il est
indispensable de se battre sans relâche
en tant que garde des sceaux il est
désormais de mon devoir de les préserver
c'est pourquoi je disais au sénatrice et
sénateurs que vous êtes ne prenons pas
de risque et protégeons autant que notre
droit le permet cette liberté
fondamentale des femmes qui est le droit
à l'IVG que les choses soient claires ne
s'agit pas d'une entreprise aisée je le
dis avec gravité on ne doit toucher à la
constitution selon la formule consacrée
que d'une main tremblante c'est pourquoi
il nous faut avoir à l'esprit que le
détail de la rédaction qui serait Infiné
retenue sera déterminant tout comme le
périmètre exact de la réforme une
rédaction inadaptée pour être en effet
conduire à consacrer un accès sans
condition à l'IVG
je pense par exemple à des IVG bien
au-delà de la limite légale en vigueur
ce qui n'est pas souhaitable nous en
convenons une écriture mal soupesée pour
être également s'avérer trop rigide et
empêcher une adaptation possible du
dispositif actuel si celle-ci s'avérait
nécessaire comme cela a d'ailleurs été
le cas en mars dernier il nous faudra au
cours des débats ici et à l'Assemblée
rester très vigilant sur les possibles
et fait de bord il nous faudra également
rester vigilant sur le choix de la place
à laquelle inscrire le droit à l'IVG
dans la Constitution afin de donner tout
son sens à cette reconnaissance toute sa
cohérence au regard naturellement des
autres dispositions constitutionnelles
mais ma crainte première
et elle semble fonder
c'est qu'il n'y est justement pas ce
débat
car j'ai pris acte du rejet du texte par
votre commission des Lois
laissez-moi vous dire avec la liberté
qui est la mienne que je le regrette
pas tant pour le détail de l'écriture de
la proposition de loi de la sénatrice
Vogel sur laquelle je rejoins d'ailleurs
un certain nombre de craintes de la
rapporteur Agnès canaillé je le regrette
car cette décision souveraine de votre
commission acte au fond un refus de
principe de constitutionnaliser le droit
à l'IVG
il n'est même pas question pour la
commission de travailler sur une
meilleure rédaction possible non il
s'agit d'un refus pur et simple qui
condamne par anticipation toute
initiative d'où qu'elle vienne or vous
le savez sans doute sans la valse du
Sénat le verrou sacré de notre
Constitution ne peut être levée
il faut pourtant que le débat vive
j'espère donc que l'hémicycle dira non
nous ne fermons pas la porte d'emblée
essayons d'avancer ensemble sur cette
proposition ou celle de la présidente
bergée ou panneau essayons d'entendre
les pour mais aussi bien sûr les contre
essayons d'entendre les craintes pour
les apaiser et surtout travaillons
ensemble pour trouver la meilleure
rédaction possible et de ne pas manquer
cette occasion alors que les planètes
s'alignent aujourd'hui pour permettre
enfin cette
constitutionnalisation je le dis et je
le regrette si le Sénat est prête à
avancer avec prudence et sans idéologie
sur cette question le gouvernement
répondra présent le fait il répond déjà
présent aujourd'hui devant vous car oui
le gouvernement vous l'avez compris est
favorable à la constitutionnalisation du
droit à l'IVG je le dis également le
gouvernement répondra présent pour
soutenir chacune des initiatives
parlementaires qui sont nombreuses dans
la matière les rédactions proposées sont
diverses et je suis persuadé que ces
initiatives je pense à celle de la
présidente Aurore berger à sa collègue
Marie-Pierre rixin qui porte toutes les
deux avec force et Constance ce combat
nous permettront d'atteindre je le crois
la meilleure rédaction possible avant de
conclure mon propos je veux dire ici à
ceux qui nous regardent il ne s'agit pas
de livrer tel ou tel parlementaire à la
vindicte des réseaux sociaux comme cela
a pu être fait
je pense
à la présidente
lors de la présentation de sa
proposition de loi j'ai éprouvé
personnellement depuis deux ans
sur de très nombreux textes
votre engagement sans farine madame la
signatrice canailler pour la défense de
notre État de droit et des droits de nos
concitoyens le débat politique il est
fait bien sûr de désaccord et tout le
monde a dans cette hémicycle le droit
d'exprimer librement ses opinions sans
crainte d'être inquiété le débat
politique il est aussi fait d'accord et
de convergence patiemment construit sur
le chemin du compromis avançons ensemble
sur ce chemin du compromis mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs comme nous
l'avons fait tant de fois
sans démagogie sans idéologie pour
renforcer à nouveau les droits de
l'homme qui sont cet après-midi ceux de
la femme
la parole est à madame Isabelle Rome
ministre délégué chargé d'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes de la diversité
et de l'égalité des chances
madame la Présidente
merci pour vos mots
c'est la première proposition de loi
qu'il me revient de soutenir aujourd'hui
devant vous comme ministre délégué
auprès de la première ministre chargé de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
je suis fière qu'il s'agisse de celle
consistante à inscrire le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
dans notre Constitution
d'entourer ce droit conquis de haute
lutte après des années de combat
féministes et grâce à l'opiniâtreté et
la force de Simone Veil de l'entourer
d'un rempart
car il faut le préserver le protéger
contre les menaces devant mauvais ou les
courants réactionnaires
se remparts doit être à la hauteur de ce
qui font notre République une libre
égale fraternelle
c'est pourquoi il est nécessaire
d'inscrire le droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse dans la
Constitution du 4 octobre 1958 vous
l'avez rappelé monsieur le garde des
sceaux il est beaucoup plus difficile de
changer une constitution que de changer
la loi qu'une autre loi une autre
majorité peut défaire en quelques mois
parce que non madame la rapporteur
malgré le respect que je peux avoir pour
vos travaux nous ne sommes à l'abri de
rien quel américaine aurait imaginé il y
a deux ou trois ans encore voir
s'effondrer la protection de ce droit
soumis désormais aux aléas politiques
des différents États membres des
États-Unis
aurait-on pensé il y a moins de deux ans
au sein même de l'Union européenne que
des états reviennent sur le droit à
l'IVG en autorisant les femmes à avorter
seulement en cas de viol ou de graves
danger ou en les contraignant à écouter
le cœur du futur avant de prendre leur
décision
depuis 2017 le gouvernement et la
majorité n'ont au contraire cessé de
renforcer la législation en matière de
droits sexuels et reproductifs en
donnant un accès gratuit à la
contraception pour toutes les femmes
jusqu'à 25 ans
en allongeant les délais d'accès à l'IVG
de 12 à 14 semaines de grossesse en
prévoyant le tiers payant intégral de
l'IVG afin notamment d'en assurer la
confidentialité et en soutenant
résolument le planning familial dont les
financements seront augmentés pour le
lancement de leur chat visant à lutter
contre la désinformation
ce combat avec François Braun ministre
de la Santé nous le poursuivons en
rendant dès l'an prochain la pilule du
lendemain gratuite sans ordonnance pour
toutes les femmes ce combat avec Eric
Dupond-Moretti garde des sous nous le
menons cet après-midi avec la
représentation nationale et je remercie
madame la sénatrice belhadimogel de nous
en donner l'occasion à travers cette
proposition de loi constitutionnelle une
proposition que porte également la
majorité parlementaire emmené par Aurore
berger
je remercie par ailleurs l'ensemble des
parlementaires engagés et
particulièrement les membres de la
délégation à l'égalité femme homme du
Sénat conduite par Annick billon avec
laquelle j'échange de manière très
régulière et très constructive
ce combat la France le mène également
hors de ses frontières c'est dans ce
sillon que le Président de la République
a affirmé le 19 janvier dernier devant
les euros députés vouloir inscrire le
droit à l'IVG dans la Charte des droits
fondamentaux de l'Union européenne
et c'est dans ce sillon que s'inscrit
notre diplomatie féministe dans le forum
génération égalité organisé à Paris en
juillet 2021 a constitué le point
culminant la contribution de la France
pour les droits sexuels et reproductifs
à l'échelle internationale ce hisse à
hauteur de 400 millions d'euros sur 5
ans
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
les droits sexuels et reproductifs
conditionnent tous les autres droits des
femmes
des tricoter écornés ou nier ses droits
constituent assurément une forme de
violence fondée sur le genre
parce que les droits des femmes sont des
droits humains ils ne sont ni chez
câbles ni hiérarchisables
ce ne sont pas des droits à moitié mais
des droits fondamentaux inaliénables
qu'il convient de protéger et de
consolider
aucune femme aucune de nos filles ne
doit vivre en France dans la peur d'être
un jour dénoncé arrêter juger pour avoir
avorté comme ce fut le cas de
Marie-Claire en 1973 jugé au tribunal de
Bobigny et remarquablement défendue par
Gisèle Halimi cette garantie notre
République doit leur apporter
c'est pour toutes ces raisons que comme
l'avait déjà exprimé la première
ministre le Gouvernement est favorable à
la constitutionnalisation de l'IVG
et n'en déplaise à l'extrême droite qui
malgré le vernis quel tente de nous
montrer n'a jamais été et ne sera jamais
l'allié des droits des femmes nous
devons être collectivement lucide
la menace d'un retour en arrière n'est
pas une chimère
l'exemple américain le pays d'Elisabeth
keddy Stenton est un avertissement
s'attaquer à l'avortement c'est
s'attaquer à toutes les femmes et c'est
s'attaquer à la liberté le gouvernement
sera toujours du côté des femmes et de
la liberté je vous remercie
merci
nous passons à la discussion de la
motion tendante à opposer la question
préalable
monsieur Stéphane Ravier a déposé une
motion distribuée sous le numéro 1
tendante à opposer la question préalable
au texte en discussion la parole est
donc à Monsieur Stéphane Ravier pour la
motion et pour trois minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre mes chers
collègues
l'immigration jusqu'au remplacement
l'islamisme jusque dans nos écoles
l'insécurité jusqu'à la barbarie la
fiscalité jusqu'au raquette la précarité
jusqu'à la pauvreté de masse les sujets
graves les sujets graves ne manquent pas
en France mais nous voilà en train de
perdre un temps précieux en discutant
d'une problématique importée des
États-Unis sans aucun rapport avec la
réalité de notre pays et c'est pourtant
ce dont les auteurs de ce texte se
réclament dans l'exposé des motifs vous
êtes hors sujet je dirais même qu'il n'y
a pas de sujet c'est pourquoi je vous
propose mes chers collègues d'enterrer
ce texte avant même son examen un texte
dangereux
inutile qui permet à ces auteurs de
faire de l'agit propre comme la lui-même
analyser et dénoncer dans le Figaro du
jour l'ancien secrétaire général du
Conseil constitutionnel Jean-Éric vous
avez voté le prolongement de
l'avortement jusqu'à 16 semaines
d'aménorrhées dans un texte de loi du
mois de mars ces attaques envers la vie
ne vous suffisent-elles pas c'est
complètement anachronique de dire que
l'avortement est menacé dans notre pays
quand il existe un délit d'entrave de
deux ans d'emprisonnement et 30 000
euros d'amende pour quiconque tenterait
d'y opposer un avis contraire en 2021 se
sont encore 223 000 avortements qui ont
été réalisés à gravats l'hiver
démographique français cela ne vous
suffit toujours pas il y a des
impératifs de santé dans notre pays dans
ce texte nous détourne l'avortement
invoqué dans le cadre pour les cas
d'urgence dans la loi veille est devenue
un avortement banalisé encouragé en 2022
pourtant il faut le rappeler ce n'est
pas un acte anodin
moi je suis plutôt inquiet des tournures
que prennent les propositions actuelles
je vous rappelle cet amendement sur
l'avortement à 9 mois 9 mois en
invoquant une détresse psychosociale
vous considérez que cet infanticide
légalisé est un progrès je considère que
c'est une union mini qui vous déshonore
souvent les femmes avortent sous la
contrainte
psychologique ou économique
accompagnons-les soutenons-les elle est
là la mission du politique il est là
notre devoir de plus sur le plan
juridique ces textes vient encombrer la
Constitution dans un dans son article 8
pourtant consacrer au pouvoir judiciaire
la Constitution régit l'organisation des
pouvoirs publics elle n'est pas une
charte de droit j'ai entendu que les
auteurs de la loi souhaitaient
constitutionnaliser un droit pour
empêcher les lois régressives je trouve
pourtant que l'adjectif régressif et
tout à fait celui qui correspond aux
infâmes loi bioéthiques que nous avons
voté que vous vous avez voté ces
dernières années et quelque chose me dit
que le pire est encore devant nous
cette proposition de loi consignée par 5
présidents de groupe écologistes
socialistes communistes connaissances et
radicaux nous donne à voir un front
commun c'est une clarification de
position pour une plus grande
clarification même si cher collègue
parole est à Madame Mélanie Vogel contre
la motion merci
je crois que vous pouvez le dire
toujours je suis toujours
c'est pas grave madame vosgienne vous
avez la parole merci Madame
[Musique]
la président j'aurais presque envie de
vous remercier évidemment je ne vais pas
le faire mais vous êtes exactement en
train de démontrer pourquoi nous sommes
en train de faire ce que nous faisons
comme le dit
comme le dit si souvent et si souvent si
bien Laurence Rossignol il n'y a pas
d'exception française
ut égard à l'extrême droite l'extrême
droite française elle est comme
l'extrême droite partout elle s'oppose
au droit des femmes elle s'oppose aux
droits sexuels et reproductifs elle
déteste tous les acquis de la République
tous les progrès que les féministes sont
acquis de haute lutte elles détestent
l'égalité des droits et la liberté et
n'ayez aucun doute chers collègues ça
détermination allait détruire si par le
pire des malheurs de l'histoire et
l'arrivée au pouvoir en France et total
évidente et parfaitement transparente on
nous raconte que le droit est l'IVG
n'est pas menacé en France qu'aucun
parti politique en France ne peut
revenir sur le droit à l'avortement et
bien voilà la force politique qui a fait
42% des voix au second tour d'action
présidentielle vient de vous prouver le
contraire alors oui c'est vrai il y a
une clarification il y a ceux dans cette
hémicycle celles et ceux qui sont en
faveur des droits et des libertés
fondamentales y compris les droits et
libertés fondamentales des femmes et
celles et ceux qui ne le sont pas alors
chers collègues la question de quel côté
êtes-vous je vous le demande encore une
fois surtout à celles et ceux qui dans
cette émission tiennent encore à tenir
l'extrême droite et son projet à
distance prenez la mesure du moment
historique que nous vivons les fascisme
progressent et avec eux les attaques de
nos droits les plus fondamentaux
personne ne sait qui gouvernement à la
France en 2027 quelle sera la prochaine
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
personne nous sommes ici une majorité je
crois dans cet assemblée a rappelé notre
attachement au droit à l'IVG et bien
prouvons-le
merci quelle est la vie de la commission
madame la rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente alors la
commission des lois n'a pas pu se réunir
mais j'aimais un avis évidemment
défavorable à cette question préalable
il est nécessaire même si nous avons des
oppositions justement que le débat
démocratique se fasse ici au Sénat de
manière calme et serein et c'est ici la
force du Sénat de pouvoir débattre en
respectant les convictions des uns et
des autres merci quelle est la vie du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
madame la présidente mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs
nous pensions avoir exposé tous les
arguments qui nous étaient venus en tête
nous avons partagé d'ailleurs un certain
nombre de ces arguments évidemment
et puis voilà que monsieur le sénateur
ravier nous chamboule vous voyez
au fond monsieur le sénateur
l'imaginaire voyez-vous et souvent le
dernier refuge de la liberté
et alors
vous nous donnez une formidable raison
de voter ce texte
non mais imaginons vous voyez imaginons
je vous le disais à l'instant
oui c'est le dernier refuge de la
liberté mais imaginons qu'un jour
imaginons qu'un jour vous soyez au
pouvoir c'est à dire plaise
moi je pense que l'avortement est
sérieusement menacé dans ce pays ouais
ah ouais
bon et puis je vais vous dire une chose
là quand on parle de droits de l'homme
et surtout de droit de la femme on n'est
jamais hors sujet monsieur le sénateur
voilà la question elle se pose quand on
vous voit quand on vous entend vous
exprimez il plus mariniste d'ailleurs il
est mourir monsieur le sénateur on va le
dire il a il a changé de de bord ouais
un peu un peu plus un peu plus allé un
peu plus à droite encore mais veille il
était il a été élu sous l'étiquette de
Marine Le Pen il est parti plus à droite
encore bon nous verrons tout ça ça c'est
de la petite politique politicienne mais
merci merci de nous avoir apporté ce
témoignage voyez moi moi monsieur le
sénateur les mots moi monsieur le
sénateur les mots que vous avez utilisé
à la tribune je n'aurais jamais
osé les prononcer merci d'être là
vraiment merci
merci monsieur le garde des sceaux je
vais passer aux explications de vote je
voudrais vous rappeler que s'agissant
d'une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle il y aura un scrutin
public et je passe la parole à Monsieur
iacovelli
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la France elle ne vit pas dans un vase
clos elle me dit pas en vase clos les
débats de société qui transcendent les
frontières et donc on ne peut pas rester
insensible et et sourd aux atteintes au
droit des femmes qui traversent les
différents pays et d'ailleurs pas
seulement outre-Atlantique je pense sur
le continent européen je pense à
l'Italie qui dernièrement avec Meloni
souhaite développer des alternatives
d'ailleurs vos amis monsieur ravier vos
amis qui sont aux responsabilités donc
Meloni des alternatives à l'avortement
et notamment en donnant une allocation
pour éviter d'avorter
en Pologne en Pologne d'autres amis
monsieur ravier en Pologne a rendu un
arrêté s'il vous plaît monsieur ravier
monsieur ravier s'il vous plaît
de grossesse en Hongrie un autre ami à
vous monsieur ravier le mois dernier a
durci la réglementation et que tout le
monde le sache aujourd'hui vous savez
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont demandé ils avons
demandé aux femmes qui souhaitent
avorter d'écouter le cœur de leur du
fœtus des enfants d'accord pour éviter
d'avorter voilà c'est ça la réalité
aujourd'hui de votre famille politique à
travers le drop et c'est ça la réalité
des attaques contre l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse alors moi je
chers collègues j'ai quatre questions à
vous poser quatre questions à vous poser
est-ce qu'on est en tant que législateur
est-ce qu'on est s'il vous plaît est-ce
qu'on est en tant que législateur est-ce
que nous soutenons le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
cette grande loi de progrès est-ce que
nous soutenons le droit des femmes à
disposer de leur corps est-ce que nous
soutenons en tant que Français nous
sommes attachés à ce que la France qui
reste ce phare des droits dans un océan
de pays qui attaquent effectivement les
droits des femmes à travers le monde et
est-ce que nous souhaitons et là je je
pose la question aussi au gouvernement
est-ce que nous souhaitons que par cette
constitutionnalisation nous puissions
pousser le gouvernement à faire en sorte
que ce droit soit effectif dans
l'ensemble des territoires et notamment
dans la ruralité alors mes chers je
voudrais juste finir non
merci chers collègues je peux pas
laisser la parole est à Monsieur le
caster bah
monsieur le castor bah vous allez la
parole
je suis désolée je donnerai la même non
je donnerai le même temps de parole pour
tout le monde je rappelle c'est 2
minutes et c'est pas 10 secondes de plus
ou 30
monsieur
collègues sommes-nous c'est na de la
République
encore capable aujourd'hui de discuter
sereinement d'un sujet essentiel pour la
vie de notre société
sommes-nous capables de laisser un
instant de côté les patients
et de faire un travail utile pour notre
pays je le souhaite
je le garde des sceaux vous avez invoqué
si votre veille
bien que j'ai été l'un de ses plus
proches collaborateurs et que je lui
soit resté fidèle jusqu'au bout je ne
parlerai pas en son nom nul n'a le droit
de le faire
mais
le vrai combat c'est elle qui l'a mené
le vrai courage c'est elle qui l'a eu
et il importe aujourd'hui encore de lui
en rendre hommage car les équilibres
qu'elle a su trouver sont ceux sur
lesquels nous vivons 50 ans un peu moins
après et c'est très important de le dire
ne déplaçons pas ces équilibres
alors monsieur le garde des sceaux je ne
comprends pas exactement votre position
vous avez parlé de symboles de beaux
symboles d'accord pour les beaux
symboles mais ici nous légiférons et
quand nous les différents sur la
constitution nous ne cherchons pas des
symboles nous cherchons à être utiles à
notre pays or à la fin de votre propos
vous n'avez pas manqué et vous ne
pouviez pas faire autrement de prendre
des distances à l'égard du texte qui
nous est proposé et de montrer que
celui-ci devrait être amélioré sur bien
des points parce qu'il ne vous paraît
pas apporter toutes les garanties
possibles par ailleurs le gouvernement
n'a pas pris l'initiative d'un projet de
loi et nous condamnerait même référendum
sur ce sujet
la parole est à Monsieur Hervé
[Applaudissements]
merci Madame la présidence madame la
ministre
le groupe de l'Union centriste ne votera
pas cette motion tendance à opposer la
question préalable parce que le débat a
eu lieu sereinement commission
madame Vogel a été invité à présenter sa
proposition de loi
ça a été un vote de la commission des
lois qui l'a permis en jarc
la rapporteur a fait un travail qui est
un travail équilibré et le débat a pu
avoir lieu le principe d'une discussion
générale c'est de permettre à tout un
chacun d'exposer son opinion et je
trouve qu'à l'instant on se parle le
débat des raps donc j'aurais pour le
coup compte de du groupe de l'Union
centriste l'occasion de rappeler la
position majoritaire dans le respect de
ceux qui voteront différemment et donc
je souhaite au nom de mon groupe que ce
débat puisse avoir lieu et que le calme
revienne
merci chers collègues alors je vais
consulter le Sénat sur la motion
tendance à opposé la question préalable
je rappelle que l'adoption de cette
motion entraînerait le rejet du texte en
discussion
en application de l'article 59 du
règlement le scrutin public ordinaire et
de droit le scrutin sera ouvert dans
quelques instants
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin numéro 7
sur la motion numéro 1 compte tenu de
l'ensemble des délégations de vote
accordée par les sénateurs au groupe
politique et notifié à la présidence
nombre de votants 345 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 345 pour l'adoption 1
contre 344 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
dans la suite de la discussion générale
je vais donner la parole à Monsieur
Stéphane Artano pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen pour 4 minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente madame monsieur les
ministres monsieur prenant la commission
des lois madame le rapporteur mes chers
collègues n'oubliez jamais qu'il suffira
d'une crise politique économique ou
religieuse pour que les droits des
femmes soient remis en question ces
droits ne sont jamais acquis vous devrez
rester vigilant votre vie durant oui
vigilants nous devons l'être mes chers
collègues c'est avertissement de Simone
de Beauvoir et tristement prémonitoire
et d'actualité en effet 50 ans après
l'adoption la loi veille force et de
constater que le droit l'avortement est
loin d'être acquis entre interdiction
totale et restriction il faut savoir que
les avortements que l'on destin provoque
en moyenne la mort d'une femme toutes
les 9 minutes dans le monde sont livrés
à un commentaire de la jurisprudence de
l'accord suprême américaine je
retiendrai que le droit à l'avortement
et l'une des premières cibles des
conservateurs excessifs alors j'entends
et d'une certaine façon je comprends les
arguments mis en avant par notre
rapporteur il n'y a rien de faux à dire
que ce procédé n'empêcherait pas d'une
part la possibilité d'une nouvelle
révision constitutionnelle afin de faire
céder la disposition protectrice notre
part son inscription pourrait anticiper
participer pardon à une inflation des
droits constitutionnels assimilable à
une à l'inflation législative les
reproches faits à la loi bavarde se
reporterait sur la constitution et plus
largement sur le bloc de
constitutionnalités tombant à devenir
trop large et perdant en efficacité à
cela vous ajoutez que le Conseil
constitutionnel défend déjà l'accès à
l'IVG comme composante de la liberté de
la femme laquelle découle de l'article 2
de la Déclaration des droits de l'homme
et du citoyen de 1789 d'un point de vue
du droit tout cela se tient de ton qu'en
France fort heureusement ceux qui
voudrait remettre en cause l'IVG et la
contraception sont extrêmement
minoritaires nous sommes donc face à un
texte
qui est un point de vue juridique on
peut justifier qu'il ne soit pas
nécessaire d'un point de vue social non
plus pour autant j'en suis cosignataire
de cette proposition portée par notre
collègue mais d'un niveau gel et je la
vauterai bien évidemment en premier lieu
parce qu'il faut y voir un moyen de
défense droit des femmes dans notre pays
en second lieu parce que c'est une façon
de dire aussi que la France ne cèdera
pas à l'obscurantisme et aux populismes
montrons l'exemple qu'on doute cèdent au
recul des idées pour la liberté et
l'émancipation
continuons à affirmer que les droits à
l'IVG à la contraception ne sauraient
être malmenés à l'avenir ils ne sont pas
tributaires d'interprétation il est trop
précaire de se résoudre sur un tel sujet
à la seule interprétation depuis 2002
par les juges d'un article datant de
plus de deux siècles par ailleurs un
revirement de jurisprudence et
d'interprétation serait trop simple à
justifier j'entends déjà ceux qui nous
expliqueraient qu'au sens strict ou
historique l'article 2 de la Déclaration
des droits de l'homme et des citoyens ne
se réfèrent ni à l'IVG ni à la
contraception autrement dit ce qui est
arrivé aux États-Unis pourrait arriver
chez nous également il faudra aller
au-delà comme le propose cette
proposition de loi la
constitutionnalisation d'un droit est un
processus efficace vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur de garde de Sceaux afin de
sanctuariser le dans le texte suprême un
droit autonome et le protéger de toute
volonté politique que ce soit celle du
législateur ou des juges
bien sûr dit qu'il y a un droit
constitutionnel fondamental ne sera pas
suffisant à faire qu'il le soit nous
devons poursuivre nos efforts ça a été
rappelé pour qu'ils soient effectif
qu'il s'inscrivent dans les mœurs
l'éducation des jeunes générations est
essentielle de ce point de vue il faut
aussi empêcher toute restriction de
personnels et de suppression de son
pratiquons l'avortement lors de
restructuration hospitalière et nous en
sommes évidemment bien d'accord vous
l'aurez compris dans sa grande majorité
le groupe RDSE votera en faveur de cette
proposition de loi
la parole est à Madame Muriel jourdat
pour le groupe les républicains pour 5
minutes chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
le Président je garde des sourds
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois madame le rapporteur mes chers
collègues à l'instar de la
quasi-totalité des sénateurs du groupe
les républicains je ne voterai pas ce
texte je ne voterai pas et j'ai peu de
temps pour vous expliquer et pourquoi je
ne voterai pas et je risque d'être un
peu brutal je le voterai tout simplement
pas parce que c'est de la mauvaise
législation
c'est de la mode des gestion et nous
sommes essentiellement des législateurs
ici nous ne sommes pas des militants
quand nous rentrons de cette hémicycle
nous desserons pas des brevets de
Morales nous ne faisons pas de la
politique fiction nous faisons la loi et
ce serait à l'évidence de la mauvaise
loi ce serait la mauvaise loi d'abord
parce que c'est un texte de réaction
réaction effectivement à une décision
qui a été prise par la Cour suprême des
États-Unis et qui vise à renvoyer aux
Etats fédérés le soin de légiférer sur
l'IVG
le fait que à moins de 6 propositions de
loi aient été déposées des montres bien
que c'est en réaction à cet événement
que ce texte nous est proposé
aujourd'hui visant à constitutionnaliser
la liberté des femmes de recourir à
l'IVG la réaction précède toujours la
réflexion et elle nous fait envisager
une situation
par la fenêtre étroite et déformante de
l'émotion plutôt que de l'envisager dans
toute sa complexité
le deuxième défaut de cette législation
et que vraisemblablement sans de vouloir
elle met à mal notre ordonnancement
juridique alors je ne suis pas une
fétichiste du droit et je pense que le
droit n'est qu'un outil mais avons qu'en
France nous avons une boîte à outils
assez garnie et si nous voulons qu'elle
reste opérationnelle il faut qu'elle
soit toujours rangée or la Constitution
contient l'organisation des pouvoirs
publics et aussi affirme un certain
nombre de droits fondamentaux le Conseil
constitutionnel nous indique quant à lui
dans une jurisprudence constante que le
droit des femmes la liberté des femmes
d'avoir recours à l'IVG et la
déclinaison d'un de ses droits
fondamentaux mais si nous inscrivons
dans la Constitution la déclinaison de
tous les droits fondamentaux au mieux
nous en ferons une espèce de code
général au pire
nous la rendrons lisible et nous en
détruirons tous les effets
cela est à peu près intangible mes chers
collègues et enfin je reprends là les
mots de monsieur le garde des sceaux ce
texte est fait pour être un symbole la
loi n'est pas un symbole la Constitution
n'est pas un symbole nous sommes tous
touchés ici par le cas des femmes
américaines qui suivent les États dans
lequel ils vivront nous pourrons plus
profiter du cette liberté d'avoir
recours à l'IVG et nous l'entendons
parfaitement mais même si la France est
le phare a été le phare des libertés
individuelles et de l'universalisme nous
ne pouvons pas nous servir de notre
Constitution comme d'un message à
envoyer aux femmes du monde entier
un texte de loi est faite pour produire
de l'effet pas pour être symbolique
alors il m'échappe pas que l'effet
escompté de ce texte et de protéger sa
liberté des femmes de recourir à
mais là encore de chaque collègue la
Constitution n'est pas un coffre-fort ou
alors le législateur en alcool depuis
fort longtemps puisque depuis 1958 nous
n'avons pas modifié la Constitution
moins de 24 fois et cet effet de guerre
protecteur mais d'autres auront le temps
de le développer après moi et puis
surtout les protéger de quoi
quel danger menace aujourd'hui la
liberté des femmes
quel danger le menace nous avons eu
récemment des élections nationales
quelle partie politique
a développé dans son programme
l'abrogation de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse aucun aucun car
cela n'est pas à l'ordre du jour
personne en France n'est opposé à l'IVG
ça ne veut pas dire que personne ne le
soit à titre personnel mais chacun garde
ça dans son fort intérieur aujourd'hui
et c'est précisément tout le danger de
ce texte car vous savez que pour aboutir
cette procédure de votre conduire au
référendum proposé par le Président de
la République chacun sait que les
résultats des référendum est clairement
sur l'état de l'opinion sur la question
posée que sur la popularité de celui qui
pose la question tout cela est très
hasardeuse me semble-t-il et surtout
lorsque nous avons affaire un tome nous
avons un débat et lors de ce débat ce
qui gardait leur opposition à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
dans leur fort intérieur et bien on se
rend amenés tout à fait légitimement à
le déposer sur la face publique et nous
ont arrivés à avec ce texte nous allons
arriver à la situation dans laquelle
pour protéger la liberté des femmes
d'une menace qui est inexistante en
France et nous les gîtons pour le seul
français et pour le droit français nous
allons remettre en débat une liberté qui
semblait pour les femmes acquises depuis
des décennies alors mes chers collègues
si véritablement vous voulez protéger ne
votez pas ce texte
leg la parole est à Monsieur Pierre Jean
verzelaine pour le groupe les
indépendants et pour 4 minutes
monsieur le garde des sceaux mes chers
collègues avant janvier 75 c'était hier
l'avortement était un délit pénal
sanctionné jusqu'à 50 prisons les
médecins pouvaient être condamnés à une
interdiction un interdiction d'exercer
et les femmes concernées elles étaient
contraintes d'aller à l'étranger ou de
recourir à des avortements clandestins
la reconnaissance de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse a été le fruit
d'un long combat on se souvient du
Manifeste des 343
on se souvient de l'acquittement de la
jeune Marie-Claire on se souvient moins
de la première tentative très encadrée
de légalisation qui a échoué en 1973 et
porté par Michel poniatovski à l'époque
ce sujet a profondément divisé la
société les débats au Parlement ce sont
déroulés dans une rare violence
Simone Veil soutenu par Jacques Chirac
par une partie de la majorité et par
l'opposition des fondations textes avec
acharnement malgré les attaques
personnelles son combat c'était celui de
toutes les femmes
lors de son discours devant l'Assemblée
nationale elle déclara aucune femme ne
recourt de gaieté de cœur à l'avortement
cette phrase
c'est évidemment toujours une réalité
car même s'il s'agit d'une décision
réfléchie pesée et assumer en avortement
demeure et demeurera toujours un
événement marquant un drame dans la vie
d'une femme
suppression de la notion de détresse
allongement des délais d'avortement
remboursement à 100% par la sécu depuis
la loi c'est adapté et a été améliorée
nous pouvons ici tous ensemble en
convenir la France n'est pas aujourd'hui
je vais je vais dire à l'heure à
laquelle on parle menacer de connaître
un retour en arrière sur ce sujet
d'ailleurs aucune parole crédible ou
reconnu comme tel ou en tout cas qui a
une certaine audience ne leur réclame ou
ne le revendique
bien attaché à la protection
fondamentale de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse certains des
collègues de mon groupe ne voient pas la
justification juridique de cette
démarche
il considère qu'il s'agit d'un texte
déclaratif qui n'aura pas d'issue
positive un symbole qui ne fera pas
avancer concrètement l'accès à l'IVG à
l'avortement et qu'en fin toucher à la
constitution sur des questions
sociétales revient à ouvrir une boîte de
Pandore c'est la raison pour laquelle
certains élus de notre groupe
s'abstiendront contre cette proposition
sur le sujet de l'IVG nous sommes forcés
de constater que toutes les autres
démocraties n'avancent pas même rythme
que la France au sein même de l'Union
européenne en Pologne une oie vient de
restreindre l'avortement qui n'est plus
autorisé qu'en cas de viol ou d'inceste
de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique la Cour
suprême a remis en cause l'avortement
chaque État est désormais libre
d'interdire l'avortement une dizaine
d'ailleurs ont déjà commencé à faire
marche arrière à nos frontières en
Italie madame Meloni qui vient de
remporter les élections assume de
favoriser le droit à ne pas recourir à
l'IVG preuve que le combat de la liberté
d'avorter n'est pas acquise là on ne
voyons penser qu'il est intouchable
madame la sénatrice
il y a certaines des convictions que
vous portez que je ne partage pas votre
conception de la société n'est pas
vraiment la mienne
le propos que vous avez tenu tout à
l'heure est un peu agressif un peu
culpabilisant et je suis pas certain que
ce soit la meilleure manière de défendre
la cause que vous portez néanmoins comme
d'autres collègues du groupe je voterai
en faveur de propositions car ce qu'une
loi a fait une autre peu la défaire ce
sera beaucoup plus difficile quand elle
sera inscrite et gravée dans le marbre
de la Constitution
pour en terminer je fais remarquer que
ça demande pas de saveur de voir celles
et ceux qui remettent en cause nos
institutions qui parlent souvent de la
Sixième République finalement s'appuyer
sur la constitution voulue par le
général de Gaulle pour protéger un droit
fondamental et essentiel des femmes de
ce pays je voulais souligner cette
avancée ainsi comme je l'exprimais dans
mon propos fidèle à l'ADN du groupe les
indépendants chacun votera selon ses
convictions merci merci chers collègues
la parole est au président Guillaume
gonta pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire pour 4 minutes
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre madame la
rapporteur mes chers collègues
qu'est-ce qu'une constitution
les étudiants en première année de droit
et de sciences politiques dès leur
premier cours de droit constitutionnels
sont soumis à cette épineuse question et
la réponse tient en trois points
premièrement un traité d'organisation
des pouvoirs publics garantissant leur
séparation deuxièmement un système de
subordination des normes et
troisièmement un corpus de droits et de
valeur la Constitution est notre norme
suprême chacun sait ici la force
juridique comme symbolique du test
constitutionnel comme des principes à
valeur constitutionnelles quand
j'entends sur nos bancs inscrire le
droit fondamental à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse dans la
Constitution ne servirait pas ou peu je
suis saisi par la surprise encore plus
après les propos abjects du sénateur
ravier alors non
la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel ne protège pas
positivement le droit à l'IVG et oui son
inscription dans le marbre
constitutionnel beaucoup plus dur à
tailler que le calcaire de la loi est
une protection considérable accordée aux
femmes
dont rêve beaucoup à travers le monde et
que l'on pleure de l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique c'est un truisme qu'il faut
étrangement répéter et vous avez raison
monsieur le ministre de le faire il est
bien plus complexe de modifier le texte
constitutionnel que la loi à fortiori
dans notre cinquième république
rationalisée où l'exécutif tient le
Parlement dans sa main de l'autre côté
des Alpes malgré sa victoire d'une
ampleur inédite la coalition des
fascistes de la droite n'est pas en
mesure de changer la constitution et
c'est un soulagement
comme la rappeler le monsieur le garde
des sceaux ne prenons pas de risque le
Funès destin politique de nos voisins
transalpins nous rappelle d'ailleurs que
si l'IVG n'est pas aujourd'hui menacé
dans notre pays il faut profiter de ce
moment pour le protéger avant qu'il ne
soit trop tard pareil
occasion ne se représentera pas
d'aussitôt alors comment inscrire le
droit à l'IVG dans le corpus de droit et
de valeur qu'est notre Constitution ce
débat est légitime et il est vrai que
dans la tradition constitutionnelle
française ses droits et valeurs sont
plutôt énumérées dans les textes
historiques qui font la grandeur de
notre pays la Déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen et le magnifique
préambule de la Constitution de 1946
texte rattaché au Préambule de la
Constitution de 1958 mais ce n'est pas
une exclusive et on retrouve tout au
long de ces articles de la Constitution
nombre de valeurs cardinales et de droit
fondamentaux de notre République parmi
lesquels l'égalité la laïcité la
souveraineté nationale l'abolition de la
peine de mort
alors que faire écrire une nouvelle
Charte des droits des femmes pour
compléter la trop masculine Déclaration
des Droits de l'Homme et du Citoyen
renforcer l'article 1 qui assure déjà la
parité politique créer un article 66-2
pour interdire l'entrave à l'IVG ce
débat est fécond et légitime mais ce
n'est pas le débat du jour nous ne
souhaitons pas aujourd'hui sur la base
de ce texte engagé un processus de
révision constitutionnel d'origine
parlementaire qui déboucherait sur un
référent d'homme nous souhaitons
aujourd'hui envoyer un message politique
au gouvernement pour le rassurer pour
lui signifier qu'il trouvera ici au
Sénat une majorité pour faire adopter un
projet de loi inscrivant le droit
fondamental à l'IVG dans notre
Constitution
libre à lui libre à vous monsieur le
garde des sceau de choisir la rédaction
qui vous conviendra le mieux de
convoquer une commission spéciale des
mines en juristes ou même une convention
citoyenne pour écrire une charge du
droit des femmes ce que nous souhaitons
aujourd'hui c'est que le Sénat se
prononce en faveur de ce principe en
faveur de ce symbole politiquement
politique extrêmement fort qui rayonnera
partout dans le monde
merci extrême alors oui c'est notre truc
la parole est à Monsieur Dominique
théophile
pour le groupe de rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes des
indépendants pour 4 minutes et merci de
respecter votre temps je le rappelle
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre madame la
rapporteur mes chers collègues
dans un mandat il y a des prises de
parole qui sont plus importantes que
d'autres il y a des textes que l'on
aborde avec le sentiment que nos mots
compte davantage cette proposition de
loi constitutionnelle en fait partie si
le groupe RDPI dans sa majorité
consignes ont consignait ce texte et
s'il est unanimement attaché au doigt
des femmes à l'IVG et à son plein accès
c'est en tant que consignataire que je
m'exprime aujourd'hui je fais une petite
fenêtre avant pour vous dire que je
viens d'un territoire où le taux
d'avortement et trois fois supérieur en
moyenne à la France et si le taux le
plus élevé de France
et où l'on ose à peine imaginer ce qu'un
recul de ce doigt pourrait provoquer je
vous laisse imaginer la proposition de
loi constitutionnelle que nous examinons
cet après-midi vise à protéger à
garantir ce doigt fondamental en
esprivant dans la Constitution nous
l'abordons alors que l'issue de nos
débats ne fait guerres de doute mais je
souhaite me tromper mais puisqu'il
s'agit de prendre rendez-vous j'aimerais
revenir sur les arguments qui ont été
avancés par la commission des lois pour
justifier le rejet du texte le premier
argument d'ordre politique consiste à
dire que le doigt à l'IVG n'est pas
menacé en France il ne l'est pas en
effet si l'on considère les professions
de froid des principaux partis
politiques ou même l'attachement des
Françaises et des Français à ses doigts
et cela mes chers collègues nous vous
rejoignons
la vraie question cependant c'est de
savoir si le doigt à l'IVG sera menacé
demain cette menace existe aujourd'hui
on l'a vu aux États-Unis et plus près de
nous en Pologne en Hongrie et même en
Italie cette menace nous la retrouvons
dans les propos actuellement passés des
responsables politiques qui s'ils ne
s'opposent pas frontalement à l'IVG ou à
la contraception cherche ainsi du
jugement insidieusement en écarter les
femmes c'est ce constat que nous sommes
nombreux à partager sur ces bancs et
dans notre pays qui nous amènent à
contester le deuxième argument soulevé
par la commission la semaine dernière
elle a estimé qu'une modification de la
constitution de s'imposait pas qu'il
s'agissait d'une mesure purement pour
pas m'asseoir et symbolique qu'il ne
prenait pas je cite d'apporter une
réponse aux difficultés d'accès à l'IVG
soit
mélangeur n'est pas ici de renforcer un
droit ou même de le rendre plus effectif
il s'agit d'empêcher un retour en
arrière en cas de changement de majorité
politique il s'agit peut-être de
politique fiction mais l'actualité nous
montre chaque jour que la fiction peut
devenir soudainement réalité il s'agit
ici de rehausser le niveau de protection
de droit qui fait désormais pleinement
partie de notre contrat social qui est
justement consacré par la Constitution
et de rendre plus difficile une
régression que la jurisprudence du
Conseil constitutionnel ne saurait
interdire aucune loi fondamentale le
protège aujourd'hui dans le monde le
doigt des femmes a avorter en
constitutionnalisant le doigt à l'IVG
notre pays ferait également
œuvre de pionnier
et fidèle à sa vocation universaliste il
enverrait un message fort au pays où le
doigt à l'avortement n'existe pas et un
message clair au pays où se doit
aujourd'hui et bafoué je terminerai en
rappelant que la constitutionnalisation
du doigt à l'IVG ne serait pas exclusive
de son inscription dans la Charte des
doigts fondamentaux de l'Union
européenne et que aux côtés du Président
de la République nous ne s'appelons de
nos vœux
c'est danse la perspective de ces
combats que nous serons nombreux au
groupe RDPI a voté ce texte là
merci chers collègues la parole est à
madame la Présidente Laurence Rossignol
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain pour 6 minutes chers
collègues
Madame et Monsieur les ministres madame
la Présidente pardon madame les
ministres madame la rapporteur je mets
chers collègues je vais d'abord madame
la rapportant m'attacher à votre rapport
selon vous l'IVG ne fait l'objet
d'aucune remise en cause aujourd'hui en
France et bien je ne partage pas votre
sérénité les courants hostiles à l'IVG
n'ont jamais des armées depuis 1975 il
dispose de moyens financiers
considérables drainé à l'international
s'appuie sur des institutions puissantes
comme la Fondation Lejeune ils sont
hyperactifs sur le net est capable
d'organiser comme il y a 15 jours des
manifestations de 600 personnes à Lyon
ce que je prends très au sérieux
aujourd'hui c'est vrai ils n'ont pas ou
peu de relais affichées dans le monde
politique mais d'autres collègues m'ont
dit avant moi qui gouvernera la France
dans 5 ans
j'en sais rien mais ce que je sais c'est
que le risque d'une coalition autour de
l'extrême droite n'est pas exclue et
j'observe que partout ou des
conservateurs des réactionnaires des
populistes d'extrême droite sont au
pouvoir partout le droit à l'IVG leur
cible et le hostilité au droit des
femmes et leur étendard je ne crois pas
mais la niveaujed a eu la gentillesse de
me citer tout à l'heure en effet à une
quelconque exception française de
l'extrême droite en la matière et pour
tout vous dire ce n'est pas un
intervention de notre collègue
représentant d'extrême droite dans le
Sénat qui m'a rassuré sur ce point
vous dites que notre PPL importe des
débats des États-Unis mais enfin il n'y
a pas besoin d'aller si loin d'autres
n'ont dit avant moi dans l'Union
européenne Malte la Pologne la Hongrie
est maintenant l'Italie sont dirigés par
des formations politiques hostiles à
l'IVG élue sur ses programmes-là sur le
hostilité à l'IVG quant à la Suède déjà
la nouvelle coalition a indiqué vous la
remettre un terme à la diplomatie
féministe nous les surveillons avec
beaucoup de vigilance vous affirmez que
le Sénat est attaché aux lois veille et
nevirt
permettez-moi madame la rapporteur de
souligner que votre attachement est
quand même assez minimaliste depuis 75
elle loiveille a été modifié cette fois
vous l'avez d'ailleurs rappelé comme un
acquis collectif vous et vous
prédécesseurs vous y êtes 6 etatiquement
opposé encore il y a 18 mois lorsqu'il a
s'agit de voter la loi Gaillot si on
vous avait écouté
l'IVG ne serait si on vous avait écouté
l'IVG ne serait toujours pas remboursé
en 1982 la loi Roudier a été rejetée par
le Sénat les femmes devraient toujours
prouver qu'elles sont réellement
détresse les mineurs devraient toujours
obtenir l'autorisation de leurs parents
et je ne suis même pas sûr que la pilule
du lendemain serait en vente libre vous
êtes terriblement prévisible
quel que soit la question dès lors qu'il
s'agit d'améliorer l'accès à l'IVG la
réponse est non
enfin quelques mots sur la phrase
maintes fois entendu qu'il ne faudrait
modifier la Constitution que d'une main
tremblante depuis 2011 le groupe LR au
Sénat a déposé 10 propositions de loi
constitutionnelles votre main ne tremble
pas toujours et sous les présidents
Chirac et Sarkozy il y a eu pas moins de
cinq réforme constitutionnelles
le vote que nous allons émettre tout à
l'heure n'est pas destiné à enrichir les
chroniques de droit constitutionnel
c'est un vote politique que la PPL soit
adoptée ou rejetée le Sénat envers un
signal et ce ne sera pas le même si nous
adoptons d'abord nous sécurisons
davantage à venir et nous enverrons un
message aux femmes et aux progressistes
qui revendiquent affrontent les
adversaires de leur liberté si le Sénat
rejette ses PPL personne ne retiendra
vos subtilités juridiques tous les
adversaires des libertés des femmes tous
ceux qui préfèrent les avortements
clandestins aux droits de choisir cela
se sentiront plus fort parce que moins
seul et appuyé par une puissante
institution à la nôtre et il reviendront
car l'IVG est le totem des
réactionnaires des conservateurs des néo
fascistes de tous ceux qui s'opposent à
l'émancipation des femmes
il y a huit jours nous étions là au même
endroit ensemble pour témoigner de notre
solidarité avec les familles iraniennes
et nous étions unanimes
et j'ai dit ce jour-là que nous devions
combattre avec la même détermination
tous les intégristes mais les
totalitarismes religieux tous ceux qui
prétendent que des lois de Dieu sont
supérieures à celles des hommes et il
n'y a pas de différence entre obliger
les femmes à dissimuler leur corps et
leur interdire de choisir quand et avec
qui elles seront maigres
qui sont les activistes antivégers
ils sont-ils ces militants qui veulent
empêcher les femmes d'avorter qui
veulent nous renvoyer aux avortements
clandestins si Vitas laissez-les vivre
les survivants et d'autres ce sont tous
des militants intégristes et
traditionnels chrétiens catholiques ou
évangéliques qui clament leur hostilité
à la liberté des femmes car il n'y a pas
plus de liberté pour les femmes dans les
idéologies religieuses qui leur imposent
le port du foulard islamique que dans
celle qui leur refusent de droit à
l'avortement ou à la contraception voilà
ce que nous voulons faire avec cette PPL
protéger les droits des femmes et dire
clairement à ceux qui refusent des
valeurs de la République que dans la
confrontation avec les intégristes de
tout poil à la fin grâce à nous c'est
toujours la République qui gagne enfin
Monsieur le gardeesse
je n'aurai qu'un mot bien sûr vos deux
interventions nous ont confortés mais
prenez la main puisque les rédactions ne
sont pas bonnes probablement
déposez-en une mais vous auriez pu aussi
amender madame leur rapporteur parce
qu'il n'est pas rare que vous Amiez les
PPL de l'opposition
mais déposer un projet de loi
épargnez-nous ces allers-retours s'ils
votent
aléatoire dites que le gouvernement ne
soutient pas simplement le Parlement
mais qu'il le veut que le droit l'IVG
soit constitutionnalisé
merci merci la parole est à Madame
Laurence Cohen pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste et
pour 4 minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le garde des sceaux mes chers
collègues je tiens tout d'abord à
remercier le groupe geste d'avoir
inscrit dans leur niche cette PPL
consignée par plus de 100 sénatrice et
sénateurs dont les membres de mon groupe
le groupe CRCE cette volonté de
constitutionnaliser le droit à l'IVG
n'est pas nouvelle cela fait 10 ans
c'est-à-dire depuis 2012 que le Parti
communiste porte cette idée notre groupe
avait déposé une PPL en ce sens dès 2017
donc avant même la Cour suprême des
États-Unis il faut avoir pu l'inscrire
dans notre espace réservé nous l'avions
proposé et nous avions tenu un débat ici
même dans l'hémicycle avions nous tort
de vouloir protéger davantage ce droit
nos craintes face à la bonté des
mouvements conservateurs et
réactionnaires étaient-elles infondées
exagérée malheureusement non je ne vais
pas faire la liste des pays qui depuis
ont pris ou prennent un chemin
inquiétant ça a été fait mais personne
ne peut affirmer ici que le monde
actuelle s'apaise et va vers un
renforcement des droits des femmes alors
avec cette PPL importe ton comme cela a
été reproché en commission des lois un
débat liés notamment à l'organisation
constitutionnelle propre aux États-Unis
mes chers collègues en France pays des
Lumières des droits de l'homme il me
semble que des signes concrets et
inquiétants existent et nous en avons
encore une preuve de la manif pour tous
au groupe procheois au mensonges des
versets sur internet pour culpabiliser
et détourner les jeunes femmes de leur
projet d'avortement en passant par
l'élection récente de 89 députés de la
droite extrême la remise en cause du
droit à l'IVG constante s'inscrivant
dans un tout cohérent d'atteinte aux
libertés individuelles d'autant qu'on ne
peut ignorer la fermeture de 58 CIVG en
2018 qui s'ajoutent à celle de 130
d'entre eux de 2000 à 2010 à cette casse
organisée s'ajoute ici en France mes
chers collègues le manque de gynécologue
renforçant les difficultés d'accès et je
pourrais ajouter l'existence de la
double clause de conscience ou encore la
non parution des décrets pour autoriser
les sages-femmes à pratiquer des IVG
instrumentales ainsi en France le droit
à l'IVG sans cesse menacé malgré
quelques récentes dispositions
législatives favorables obtenu mes chers
collègues contre la vie de la majorité
sénatoriale et je pense particulièrement
à la loi Gaillot maîtriser le corps des
femmes vieilles lunes du patriarcat est
un enjeu de pouvoir sinon comment
comprendre qu'il est remis en cause
partout toutes ces attaques sont
révélatrices du fait que les femmes sont
toujours considérées comme des êtres
mineurs qu'il faut encadrer contrôler
car elles ne peuvent décider seul alors
que ce droit soit inscrit dans le Code
de la santé publique la question qui
nous est donc posée aujourd'hui et la
suivante est-ce que ce droitment conquis
par la lutte des féministes des
progressistes a besoin d'être protégés
au regard des quelques éléments que je
viens de citer cela ne fait aucun doute
et la question de l'emplacement dans la
Constitution est en réalité secondaire
et ne peut servir de prétexte pour ne
pas soutenir cette loi de quoi avez-vous
peur mes chers collègues de dénaturer
notre Constitution je remarque que
celles et ceux qui s'opposent à la
constitutionnalisation du roi à l'IVG et
à la contraception sous le prétexte
juridique que cela ne serait pas
nécessaire sont les mêmes qui s'opposent
systématiquement on renforcement de ce
droit et d'une manière générale qui
s'oppose à la conquête de nouveaux
droits pour les femmes depuis des années
aujourd'hui encore que cela vous plaise
ou non les femmes veulent maîtriser leur
fécondité et choisir ou non de mener à
bien une grossesse notre corps nos choix
nos droits mes chers collègues leur est
à regarder objectivement ce qui se passe
en France à l'aune de ce qui se passe
également en Europe ou dans le monde
nous croyons pas dans un état de droit
qui serait meilleur et plus solide
qu'ailleurs le garde des sceaux l'a
souligner utilisons au contraire tous
les outils de notre disposition pour
renforcer notre législation actuelle
face à un droit de toutes parts menacée
50 ans après le procès de Bobigny
pour ne pas dire merci beaucoup
je
vais passer la parole à Monsieur Loïc
Hervé pour le groupe Union centriste
pour 6 minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le garde des sceaux monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
madame la rapporteur madame l'auteur de
la proposition de loi constitutionnelle
mais chers collègues la volonté
d'inscrire l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse et la contraception dans le
marbre constitutionnel n'est pas
nouvelle et ce n'est pas moins de 6
propositions de loi qui ont été déposées
entre fin juin et début septembre 2022
sur les bureaux des deux assemblées
françaises c'est bien évidemment
l'actualité américaine qui fait que nous
cijons cet après-midi c'est même
l'actualité d'une juridiction la Cour
suprême des États-Unis ou un revirement
du risque prudence l'arrêt d'obs version
Jackson cette année est venu modifier
l'arrêt rot versus Wade du 22 janvier
1973 qui avait accordé une protection
fédérale à l'avortement sur le fondement
du 14e amendement de la Constitution des
États-Unis lequel dispose notamment
qu'aucun État ne privera quiconque de la
vie de la liberté ou la propriété
procédure légale régulière désormais aux
États-Unis d'Amérique la question de
l'avortement est redevenue une
compétence des États fédérés
chers collègues Mélanie Vogel vous avez
commencé votre votre intervention en
disant que la Constitution fonderait le
Condra le contrat social c'est donc
confier à notre texte fondamentale une
fonction qui ne peut évidemment pas être
la sienne je m'explique si votre
proposition de loi était adoptée dans
les mêmes termes au Sénat puis à
l'Assemblée nationale et enfin par une
ratification populaire par référendum
c'est le Conseil constitutionnel qui
deviendrait l'instance en charge de
veiller à la portée du texte lui-même
c'est risqué de posséder la
représentation nationale de la capacité
à modifier les règles qui encadrent
l'IVG et la contraception depuis 2008 le
Conseil constitutionnel peut être saisi
de QPC qui permettrait de rendre
contraire à la constitution des
dispositions législatives plus anciennes
encore c'est donc à des membres nommés
par le Président de la République celui
du Sénat ou de l'Assemblée nationale
qu'il reviendrait donc décider qu'il
soit davantage conservateur ou davantage
progressiste avec par principe l'absence
de tout contrôle démocratique de cette
institution notre pays conformément
l'article premier de notre constitution
de République indivisible c'est-à-dire
que le législateur dispose d'une
plénitude de compétences et les lois
appliquées de la même manière à chacun
de nos concitoyens sur l'ensemble du
territoire national c'est égard aucune
comparaison avec les États-Unis n'est
possible je voudrais revenir sur deux
lois qui aujourd'hui définissent l'accès
à l'IVG et à la contraception d'une part
la loi du 17 janvier 1975 porté par
Simone Veil et personne ne peut remettre
en cause évidemment les liens qui
unissent le groupe Union centriste et
Madame veille madame Veil est alors
ministre de la Santé elle a porté la loi
sur l'IVG qui est venue encadrer la
dépénalisation de l'avortement dans
notre pays depuis les conditions n'ont
jamais cessé d'évoluer avec notamment
son remboursement le possible acc une
femme mineure sans consentement d'un
adulte la suppression des notions de
situation de détresse et de délai
obligatoire de réflexion d'autre part la
loi du 28 décembre 1967 portée par
Lucien nevirth relative à la régulation
des naissances depuis l'accès à la
contraception à lui aussi évolué
considérablement au fil des années il
semble important de rappeler qu'aucun
parti politique n'a jamais appelé à
remettre en cause l'IVG dans son
principe et encore moins la
contraception nous serons tout juste
d'élections électorales majeures nous
n'avons entendu aucun candidat à la
présidentielle y compris aux extrêmes de
l'échiquier politique remettre en cause
les acquis de la loi Veil et la loi
nevirte aucun candidat à la
présidentielle autrement dit le risque
politique que vous invoquez en France en
2022 n'existe pas et c'est tant mieux
notre collègue Mélanie Vogel a insisté
en commission sur le fait que justement
c'est parce que ce droit n'est pas
encore menacé qu'il faudrait modifier
notre norme fondamentale qu'après il
serait trop tard cet argument ne m'a
évidemment pas convaincu
par ailleurs mes chers collègues
n'oublions pas le vrai sujet dans un
conseil dans un contexte de
désertification médicale c'est le membre
de la délégation droit des femmes qui le
dit l'accès à l'IVG est parfois rendu
très difficile notamment afin d'obtenir
les rendez-vous médicaux obligatoires
les plus touchés ce sont les femmes
originaires des territoires ruraux si le
droit existe il n'est pas appliqué de
manière pleine et entière sur le
territoire de notre pays alors avant de
s'interroger sur la nécessité avant tout
symbolique de l'inscription dans la
Constitution nous devons le gouvernement
doit se préoccuper de l'effectivité de
l'application de la loi il est 20
d'inscrire à ce droit dans la
Constitution si au quotidien dans
l'ensemble de nos territoires certaines
de nos compatriotes ne peuvent pas ils
concreto sont prévaloir notre commission
des affaires sociales et la délégation
droit des femmes du Sénat se sont
intéressés
assez complexité elles estiment que ces
sujets reposent avant tout sur
l'organisation du système de soins et
sur des mesures concrètes du pouvoir
réglementaire dépassant alors largement
le débat que nous avons cet après-midi
sur la révision constitutionnelle
en respectant les collègues de mon
groupe qui ont signé cette proposition
de loi constitutionnelle ou ceux qui
s'apprêtent à voter pour cette
proposition de loi constitutionnelle le
groupe de l'Union centriste dans sa
majorité suivra les conclusions de
Madame la rapporteur Agnès canayé et
nous soutiendra pas l'adoption de ce
texte merci chers collègues me donner la
parole à Madame Estelle
pour 3 minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur monsieur le ministre madame
la ministre chers collègues la lutte
pour la légalisation de l'IVG a été
d'abord incarné par Gisèle Halimi
signataire du manifeste des 343
ces françaises courageuses ont alors
publiquement assumer leur avortement
malgré les poursuites pénales encourues
sans suivi le procès de Bobigny en 1972
qui bouleversa l'opinion et ouvrit la
voie trois ans plus tard à la fameuse
loi Veil dont je salue l'oeuvre et la
mémoire nous ne voulons pas de retour en
arrière nous sommes probablement
quelques-unes dans cette assemblée à
avoir avorté
même aujourd'hui nous n'osons pas le
dire ouvertement en raison des
convenances qui régissent encore notre
milieu j'en fais partie
en revanche nos tours est venu de
protéger nos filles nos sœurs et nos
concitoyens en leur garantissant
formellement le droit de choisir leur
maternité sans souffrance sans honte ni
culpabilité nous voulons librement
disposer de notre corps aux hommes la
société accorde bien le privilège de
choisir leur paternité y compris le
droit de reconnaître ou non leur enfant
pourquoi la sexualité féminine
devrait-elle toujours être contrôlée le
contexte social est particulièrement
difficile où l'extrême droite ne cesse
de gagner du terrain la menace d'un
Donald Trump français à l'Élysée dans
quelques années n'est pas illusoire il
nous faut donc légiférer sans plus
attendre pour empêcher qu'un jour la
majorité au pouvoir puisse décider de
revenir sur ce droit fondamental sans
qu'il y ait face à elle une véritable
armure constitutionnel je tiens à saluer
l'initiative parlementaire de ma
collègue Mélanie Vogel et de ses
consignateurs de ce texte de ce texte
qui permet ce débat et porte le droit à
l'avortement et à la contraception
jusqu'au sommet de notre ordre juridique
en même temps nous connaissons tous ici
la difficulté d'un référendum sur une
telle PPL était adoptée dans les mêmes
termes par deux chambres
particulièrement en cette période
politique instable j'appelle donc
l'exécutive à se saisir de ce texte et à
le faire sien par un projet de loi je
profite également de cet intervention
pour demander au président de la
République de faire transférer la
dépouille de Gisèle Halimi au Panthéon
son combat a contribué à changer la vie
de millions de Françaises sa place est
auprès de Simone Veil
merci beaucoup chers collègues la parole
est à Madame Marie merci pour le groupe
les républicains pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame le Président monsieur le garde
des sceaux madame la ministre monsieur
le Président d'acquisition des lois
madame le rapporteur Michel collègue
faut-il inscrire le droit à diriger dans
la Constitution cela est-il nécessaire
et utile pour garantir son accès aux
femmes à part quelques groupuscules
personnes ne remet en cause cette
liberté des femmes dans notre pays ni la
loi veille 220 000
IVG en France pour 700 000 naissances
l'inscription de ce droit dans la
Constitution c'est une fausse bonne idée
pour ne pas dire une fausse protection
c'est un principe général qui serait
inscrit dans la Constitution deux points
les femmes ont le droit d'avorter mais
les modalités resteraient définies par
une loi qui pourrait en restreindre les
concours
même en ce moment restreindre ses
concours par rapport à ceux qui sont en
vigueur aujourd'hui par ailleurs si les
plus compliqué de modifier la
Constitution qu'une loi c'est pour
autant possible et nous l'avons vu
j'ajouterai en tant que médecin et le
local par le montant défenseur convaincu
et déterminer des droits des femmes et
de l'IVG que tant de droits humains
nécessite d'être protégé tant de noble
cause et de grands principes méritent
d'être
sanctuarisés comment imaginer possible
de tous les faire entrer dans la
Constitution et qui peut déterminer
entre eux une priorité et je pense à
l'inceste
utile mais nous encore moins peut-être
même dangereux s'il devait y avoir
référendum campagne et débat les
répercussions pour être malheureuse
inattendues imprévisible pour les femmes
alors où notre démocratie est fatiguée
ou le socle de notre vie commune est
malmenée inscrire le droit à l'IVG dans
la Constitution c'est d'ailleurs avoir
si peu confiance en l'avenir de notre
démocratie vous avez si peur de 2027 la
seule vraie garantie que nous ayons à ce
que ce droit demeure consiste à protéger
animer notre vie démocratique à éduquer
nos enfants à la démocratie au vote au
respect de l'autre à la protection des
plus fragiles seul le populisme l'ultra
conservatisme les dérives autoritaires
les gouvernements rétrogrades amènent
une régression démocratique et menace le
toit à l'avortement notre vrai combat
est là d'ailleurs elle observation du
monde en quoi la Constitution
serait-elle un obstacle aux ennemis de
la démocratie et du droit des femmes il
y a là une naïveté à le penser peut-être
une fausse thépolitique à prétendre le
contraire or il faut se parler vrai se
parler juste sanctuariser le droit à
l'IVG passe par la préservation de nos
institutions très différentes des
États-Unis par exemple et à la
préservation je le redis de notre
démocratie
alors y a-t-il quelque chose à faire ben
oui oui une loi doit être assortie d'une
obligation de moyens il faut soutenir
les plannings familiaux promouvoir les
médecins et les infirmiers scolaires
lutter contre la soudanification
médicale et les inégalités territoriales
une maternité qui ferme c'est
potentiellement aussi un centre privé
qui disparaît dans une scène du film
Simone on voit Simone Veil ministre de
la Santé refusé de rentrer dans une
chambre vide elle refuse de faire
semblant en adoptant des postures
purement symboliques quelles leçons les
femmes méritent en effet mieux qu'à
faire semblant qu'une inscription dans
la Constitution au cas où qu'un faux
semblant en réalité alors oui il faut
prévenir et protéger il faut prévenir en
informant par une éducation sexuelle
sérieuse nos jeunes garçons et filles il
faut protéger les femmes c'est-à-dire
permettre un égal accès à l'IVG pour
toutes
les conditions médicales correcte par
des professionnels formés et à leur
écoute c'est à dire aussi les
accompagner ensuite dans l'après avec
une prise en charge adaptée voilà ce qui
servirait réellement la cause des femmes
voilà ce que nous sommes en droit
d'exiger voilà ce que nous sommes en
droit d'obtenir
si chaque collègue la discussion
générale est close la commission n'ayant
pas élaboré de texte nous passons à la
discussion de l'article unique de la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
initiale et j'ai une demande de prise de
parole monsieur le Kester Philippe Bas
merci madame la présidente madame
Rossignol je la cite veut envoyer un
message
le garde des sceaux je le cite nous dit
quel beau symbole ce serait mais nous
devons écrire le droit
nous devons écrire la législation et de
ce point de vue je veux dire ma
conviction
que ce texte n'est pas seulement
inutile il serait également
inefficace du point de vue des objectifs
que ça signe ces auteurs et j'attends en
juriste qu'on vient de me démontrer le
contraire tout d'abord il est
inutile pourquoi est-il inutile parce
que le Conseil constitutionnel dès 1975
à valider la loi sur l'IVG en soulignant
que son article premier qui énonce le
respect de tout être humain dès le
commencement de la vie doit pouvoir
connaître des limites et ses limites en
cas de nécessité c'est justement l'IVG
et en 2001 le Conseil constitutionnel
est allé beaucoup plus loin puisqu'il a
dit que sa résultait de la liberté de la
femme enceinte qui trouve son fondement
dans les articles 2 et 4 de la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen c'est donc inutile c'est aussi
inefficace car toutes les avancées selon
ce qui se sont exprimés dans ce sens qui
est ont été mis en place depuis la loi
veille le délai passé à 12 et 14
semaines le remboursement la suppression
de la condition de détresse le
raccourcissement du délai de réflexion
l'accès des mineurs à l'IVG et bien
aucune de ces avancées entre guillemets
ne serait susceptible d'être protégé par
la rédaction qui a été proposée c'est
très simple à partir du moment où on
programme le libre accès à l'IVG mais
qu'on reconnaît qu'il ne peut pas être
illimité le législateur garderait
pleinement compétences pour apporter des
restrictions à l'exercice du droit à
l'IVG c'est donc à la fois
inutile et même efficace merci la parole
est à Monsieur
hériter rouge
merci Madame merci madame la Présidente
il n'y a pas que les civilisations qui
sont mortelles il y a également les
édifices juridiques la conquête en
général se fait par le droit mais le
recul et les remises en cause peuvent
également se faire par le droit et
croire que le droit et le droit
notamment dégagé par le Conseil
constitutionnel suffit à nous sauver est
une grave erreur parce que c'est comme
croire l'histoire du loup et des trois
petits cochons et penser que justement
le loup parce que le loup est présent on
a eu un petit louveteau qui s'est
exprimé tout à l'heure
et bien le loup est toujours là et il
peut souffler le vent et détruire les
édifices juridiques dans la décision
rôle versus Waid ou plus exactement dans
la façon dont elle a été remise en cause
les arguments sont très simples c'était
de dire que cette décision n'était
qu'une décision juridique que elle
constituait une décision
erronée et qu'elle constituée un abus
d'autorité judiciaire et dans les
décisions préparatoires qui ont été
menées il y avait des considérations qui
n'étaient pas des considérations
juridiques comme je cite le fait que un
être humain qui n'est pas encore né tué
un être humain qui n'est pas encore né
pose des problèmes de morale ça ce n'est
pas du droit c'est de l'idéologie et
quand on dit un petit peu plus loin que
la question de la vie des Américaines
n'a pas été vraiment transformé par par
la décision Reversus Wade c'est encore
de l'idéologie alors en effet ce texte
aurait pu être amélioré vous aurez pu
l'améliorer mais vous n'avez choisi de
ne pas le faire et je finirai par un
point le grand puisque féliba est
sensible au droit le grand
constitutionnaliste anglais William
beage haute disait au 19 siècle qui
avait deux parties dans la Constitution
il y avait une partie efficace et il y
avait une partie qui suscite le respect
et bien j'aurais voulu que cette
après-midi ensemble nous aurions nous
aurions pu construire justement un texte
qui pour toute et pour tous suscite le
respect merci la parole est à Madame
Michel meunier
merci Madame
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
la proposition de loi qui nous réunit ce
soir vise à inscrire le droit à l'IVG
dans la Constitution avec celle et ceux
qui ont déposé ces propositions de loi
nous voulons affirmer encore avec plus
de détermination ce droit des femmes à
disposer de leur corps dans notre pays
je ne reviens pas sur les arguments
juridiques et changer ici et promu par
la droite de ses bancs pour repousser
cette inscription de la dans la
Constitution en fait notre combat est
politique et symbolique Laurence
Rossignol la rappeler à la tribune il
vise à soutenir encore et toujours les
femmes qui souhaitent une IVG nous
assistons impuissante à un recul du
droit d'accès à l'avortement dans le
monde mais aussi en France où ce droit
est de plus en plus attaqué par des
franges minoritaires et réactionnaires
qui se base sur des fondements religieux
personnels pour les imposer au plus
grand nombre nous ne pouvons pas laisser
passer cela dernièrement à Nantes lors
d'un rassemblement au soutien aux femmes
dans le monde privé du droit à
l'avortement des banderoles haineuses
ont été brandis par des Antilles des
inscriptions ont saluent on salit notre
trottoir assimilant l'IVG à un génocide
cela n'est pas tolérable j'attendais de
l'ensemble de nos groupes politiques au
Sénat une forme d'unanimité de consensus
dans ce soutien à la
constitutionnalisée
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG pardon
elle n'est pas au rendez-vous et je le
regrette combien de temps encore notre
majorité va-t-elle entretenir le flou
avec cet arc réactionnaire ne
pensez-vous pas que notre famille
politique risque de se déshonorer par un
tel silence
merci chers collègues
même de la Gontrie
merci madame la Présidente évidemment
notre groupe votera ce texte et nous
remercions Mélanie vosgel d'avoir pris
l'initiative pour son groupe de le
situer dans un temps de débat
parlementaire qui peut lui être consacré
nous avons été coteur avec elle mais
j'ai entendu des propos à la droite de
cette hémicycle qui me surprennent parce
que je les avais connu dans d'autres
circonstances plus courageux plus
sincère
car les argusies juridiques avançaient
par
Philippe Bas ne sont pas opérants et ce
qui est très intéressant c'est de devoir
finalement avoir recours à ces argusies
quand on n'a pas le courage de dire
simplement je suis hostile à l'IVG
pourquoi ne sont-ils pas opérants parce
que
président ba président ba vos arguments
ne sont pas opérants parce que vous vous
référez à une jurisprudence or la
jurisprudence vous le savez très bien
peut-être changer si évoluer s'il vous
plaît ne vous inquiétez pas madame la
Présidente je poursuivrai mon propos
quoi qu'il arrive
mais je vous remercie vous êtes
responsable mais
se référer à la jurisprudence vous le
savez bien président ba c'est une
faiblesse pourquoi parce que cette
jurisprudence peut évoluer on a
suffisamment parlé de l'exemple
américain mais c'est une bonne
illustration vous le savez très bien la
jurisprudence du Conseil constitutionnel
n'est qu'une jurisprudence ce que nous
voulons c'est que désormais ce soit
inscrit dans la loi vous dites ici que
nous sommes des législateurs oui nous
sommes des législateurs nous sommes
aussi des responsables politiques
et nous avons aussi à référer aux
électeurs et aux Français et donc je le
dis au président ba ayez le courage
d'assumer votre position vous tous à
droite qui vous a prêté à refuser ce
texte
merci
alors je vais mettre au revoir l'article
unique constituant l'ensemble de la
proposition de loi constitutionnelles le
vote sur l'article vaudra votre sur
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi y
a-t-il des demandes d'explication de
vote monsieur lequesterba
je suis ravier
madame la Présidente tout d'abord je me
suis senti insulter par les propos de
Madame de La Gontrie
je n'y reviens pas mais je tenais à le
dire
je voudrais dire ici que nous sommes
tous ouverts au débat et nous avons
voulu que ce débat ait lieu nous aurions
pu l'empêcher
mais
d'agiter des idées générales qui sont
parfois aussi des idées creuses je
regrette de les dire nous avons à
discuter d'un texte nous ne l'avons même
pas fait ici nous aurions dû le faire
c'est un mauvais texte revenait avec un
bon texte nous en reparlerons
merci Monsieur ravier
quelle est l'argument des porteurs de
cette
proposition de constitutionnalisation de
l'IVG quelle est l'argument juridique
qui repose sur des déclarations qui
reposerait sur des déclarations sur des
prises de position
peut-être que un jour s'il y a une
catastrophe économique militaire
environnementale où je ne sais trop quoi
peut-être qu'il y aurait un pouvoir qui
serait amené à vouloir changer peut-être
la loi
vous reposer votre démarche repose sur
du fantasme vous êtes dans une volonté
de créer une sorte de phobie vous êtes
en réalité dans une volonté de diviser
de faire de l'agitation de faire de la
provocation jusqu'à comme la si bien dit
notre collègue Philippe Bas jusqu'à
insulter jusqu'à insulter les sénateurs
qui n'abandonnent pas dans votre sens
jusqu'à la dernière virgule jusqu'à la
dernière lettre de votre texte parce que
même quand on ne met pas encore et
personne ici ne remet en cause le droit
à l'IVG même quand on ne remet pas en
cause l'IVG vous poussez le bouchon
toujours plus loin vous êtes constamment
dans la provocation pour exister pour
exister politiquement c'est un coup
politique que vous essayez de mettre en
place aujourd'hui cela a été très bien
dit par l'ancien secrétaire général
encore une fois du Conseil
constitutionnel vous êtes dans l'agit
propre qui n'est vraiment pas propre
pour le coup vous êtes dans la
propagande toujours du walkisme que vous
voulez toujours porter ça ne prend pas
ça ne prend pas donc
je vous le confirme vous pourrez
toujours continuer
pendant vous pouvez toujours compter sur
moi vous pourrez toujours compter sur
moi pour dénoncer vos méthodes qui nous
rappellent les méthodes de fou qui est
un ville sauf qu'aujourd'hui et bien
monsieur Fouquet est un ville et sur les
talons merci merci chers
d'abord un autre collègue gravier je ne
crois pas un mot de ce qu'il nous dit je
ne crois pas un mot de ces dénégation
lui ce courant politique auquel il
appartient les courants politiques
auquel il appartient les auteurs
auxquels ils se réfèrent par
continuellement d'avortement de confort
et d'avortement de convenance je sais
depuis des années que les mots
avortement de confort et avortement de
convenance n'ont qu'une finalité réduire
le droit des femmes à l'avortement en
soumettant leur accès un jugement
extérieur sur les raisons qui les
amènent à avorter donc voilà pourquoi
vous êtes un représentant d'un courant
politique dangereux pour l'IVG quand à
mes collègues de droite j'écoute avec
intérêt
leurs explications juridiques mais je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure je vais le
redire
j'ai un peu d'expérience avec vous et 12
ans que je suis là bientôt 12 ans que je
défends les droits des femmes à disposer
de leur corps 12 ans que j'ai défendais
de texte en faveur de l'égalité d'accès
à l'IVG en faveur de l'allongement des
délais en faveur de la suppression de la
condition de détresse 12 ans que je
défendu un texte ici en tant que
ministre pour sanctionner les sites
Internet qui trompent les femmes en les
attirant sous prétexte de les informer
pour les dissuader de recourir à l'IVG
pas une fois pas une fois vous n'avez
trouvé que ce que nous disions valait la
peine d'être voté alors comme dit
l'adage au bout d'un moment des
pointillés ça fait une ligne et quand
jamais jamais le droit ne vous convient
c'est que c'est plus le droit de sujet
c'est le fond du dossier dont nous
discutons alors votez une fois une fois
un texte en faveur de divg et après je
vous croirai
merci Monsieur Brisson
[Applaudissements]
qui a la parole s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît madame la Présidente
monsieur Brisson à seul la parole merci
s'il vous plaît
merci madame la Présidente je n'avais
pas l'intention d'intervenir
j'interviens après les propos de la
country et de Madame Rossignol et je
veux dire à Philippe Bas toute notre
solidarité notre amitié
[Applaudissements]
je ne suis pas juriste comme Philippe
Bas mais je sais que trois choses
d'abord c'est que la France n'est pas la
mérite que le contexte constitutionnel
et juridique ne sont absolument pas les
mêmes que la France n'est pas un État
fédéral qu'elle n'a pas tranché entre
l'État fédéral et les États fédérés et
que son rapport à la constitution
historiquement n'est absolument pas le
même que les États-Unis d'Amérique
je dis deuxièmement et avec force
comme que je suis favorable à l'ensemble
des lois qui autorisent le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et que je me battrai pour les défendre
si elles étaient menacées
c'est ma conviction
[Applaudissements]
mais j'ai aussi ma conviction c'est que
notre Constitution ne peut pas être
soumise au débat et aux émotions qui
viennent d'autres attentes
j'ajouterai concernant la défense des
droits des femmes dans Madame Rossignol
veut dans cette assemblée faire son
monopole j'ajouterai que notre majorité
sanatoriale avec les travaux de la
délégation au droit des femmes en
particulier a fait dans le dernier
rapport auquel vous avez participé
madame Rossignol mais aussi avec
Alexandra bourquieux fontaine de grandes
avancées et que c'est ici que ça s'est
passé et que c'est la majorité c'est
notoriales qui a porté ce débat
merci chers collègues madame Cohen
[Applaudissements]
mes chers collègues moi je trouve que
dramatiser le débat comme vous le faites
sur les bancs de droite ça n'est pas
digne je vous ai écouté je vous ai
écouté ça n'est pas digne du Sénat
pourquoi je dis ça pourquoi je dis ça
parce que quel que soit ce que l'on peut
porter jusqu'à présent on a un respect
mutuel les uns envers les autres je ne
parle je ne parle pas je ne parle pas de
la droite extrême à laquelle je ne
réponds pas elle serait lui donner trop
d'honneur et je ne confonds pas mais mes
chers collègues à droite vous devez
prendre quand même vos responsabilités
les lois qui ont été jusqu'à présent
voter y compris loi Veil une très grande
dame extrêmement courageuse
pourquoi cette loi arrive au Parlement
d'abord par la mobilisation des femmes
des féministes parce que rien ne
s'obtient sans qu'il y ait un rapport de
force dans la rue ça c'est la première
chose et la deuxième chose elle n'aurait
jamais été votée s'il y avait pas eu la
mobilisation totale de la gauche donc ça
c'est aussi quelque chose d'important ça
ne vous plaît pas mais ce sont les
fesses et factuel alors au lieu
d'essayer de prendre des prétextes
jusqu'à présent moi j'ai l'habitude
depuis 2011 d'avoir un sénat responsable
quand il y a une loi qui est pas tout à
fait bien ficelée il y a des
propositions pour la pour faire en sorte
qu'on puisse la voter ensemble si vous
étiez vraiment d'accord pour protéger le
droit à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse vous l'auriez fait le fond du
problème c'est que vous allez envoyer un
message qui dit que vous n'êtes pas
d'accord et c'est ce que l'on vit à
chaque fois que l'on défend le droit des
femmes à disposer de leur corps c'est la
réalité des faits que ça ne vous plaise
pas changez vos votes
merci monsieur le Président buffet
la présidente la ministre monsieur le
ministre chers collègues
première point
vous ne pouvez pas dire monsieur
collègue madame de La Gonterie à
Philippe Bas qui lui contre l'IVG il a
été il a rappelé tout à l'heure
oui mais la vérité et le respect des
gens est aussi une des règles de notre
haute assemblée il était le plus proche
collaborateur de Madame Simone Weil il a
lui-même rédigé une partie du texte et
il l'a soutenu est-ce que vous le
contestez est-ce que vous contestez ce
fait est-ce que vous contestez ce fait
est-ce que vous contestez ce fait
la polémique bien sûr et bien voyons
votre réponse se suffit à qualifier
votre attitude je n'en dirai pas plus
enfin
j'ai entendu avec intérêt les propos de
Monsieur Gontard tout à l'heure à la
tribune
reconnaissant à demi-mots la difficulté
du texte les problématiques posées tout
en disant que il faudrait trouver le
moyen de progresser il y a plusieurs
initiatives le ministre nous l'a dit
tout à l'heure par le menteur mais Lady
vosgel au sein de notre assemblée mais
également d'autres collègues à
l'Assemblée nationale il y a donc une
mobilisation réelle sur cette thématique
moi je crois que
je crois que ce qui serait intéressant
c'est que le gouvernement parce qu'il
est le gouvernement puisse mettre un peu
d'ordre dans tout cela et ça nous
permettrait peut-être d'avancer dans un
débat serein
sérieux avec effectivement des
propositions qui pourraient peut-être
venir des différents bancs de cette
assemblée mais qui ont tous les cas ne
sortira de l'impasse de cette discussion
qui ma foi parfois d'érable de façon
tout à fait inutile alors que nous
sommes tous d'accord sans exception pour
protéger les droits des femmes
naturellement alors de grâce si on
pouvait terminer ce débat sans invective
et en étant à peu près sérieux parce que
le débat que nous ont donné les images
que nous venons de donner c'est
potentiellement celle qui pourrait se
passer en cas de référendum en France je
pense qu'on n'a pas besoin de cela sur
une initiative du gouvernement nous
aurions à ce moment-là d'autres portes
de sortie juridique beaucoup plus
sérieuses je vous remercie
merci monsieur yakovelli
monsieur yakovelli
oui je suis désolé de rompre peut-être
cette proposition mais je voudrais le
répondre au collègues Brisson
j'entends bien que vous nous donniez des
leçons et que vous essayez aujourd'hui
de défendre une loi une loi qui je vous
rappelle vous n'avez pas voté une loi
qui vous avez même voté la motion
préalable en première lecture et en
deuxième lecture alors venir nous donner
maintenant des leçons de morale sur la
défense de l'IVG et la défense du droit
des femmes c'est un peu fort de café
merci Madame gréaume
chers collègues je vais pas faire le
procès d'attention de personnes je vais
simplement rappeler la loi française la
loi française elle garantit le respect
de l'autonomie personnelle sur les
droits procréation et l'accès aux soins
et services de santé toute personne a le
droit à une contraception adaptée
gratuite ainsi que le recours librement
à l'IVG le fait de passer cette loi dans
la Constitution devient un droit
fondamental et assure la pérennité à
travers la stabilité de la constitution
du respect de l'autonomie personnelle
on oblige personne c'est simplement la
personne qu'il désire pour pouvoir y
accéder je rappelle que c'est sur
l'autonomie personnelle merci
merci alors je vais mettre au voile
article unique constituant l'ensemble de
la proposition de loi constitutionnelles
visant à protéger et à garantir le droit
fondamental à l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse et à la contraception en
application de l'article 59 du règlement
le scrutin public est de droit il va
être procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin sera ouvert dans
quelques instants le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter
le scrutin est clos
alors voici le résultat du scrutin
numéro 8 sur l'ensemble du texte et
contenu de l'ensemble des délégations de
vote accordée par les sénateurs au
groupe politique et notifié à la
présidence nombre de votants 336 nombre
de suffrages exprimés 311 pour
l'adoption 139 contre 172 le Sénat n'a
pas adopté
alors je vais suspendre la séance pour
quelques instants afin de permettre à
chacun de s'installer pour le prochain
point à l'ordre du jour la séance est
suspendue